Vediamo un po' il volume tuo che
spaccato i timpani.
Ok, connessione eccellente e via. Dai de
gas.
Allora,
lezione numero 3. Che cosa andiamo a
vedere nella lezione numero tre? che è
un po' il un argomento che avevo
trattato
eh forse nella chiamata
preinizio percorso, diciamo,
ma che è importante coprire a fondo,
diciamo,
per questi fantastici eventi e che sono
le le aste del tesoro, no, che creano
volatilità, specialmente su
sulle Treasury, non sono solitamente
volatili come un un
release di news normale, ma ehm ma
comunque in un in una settimana ce ne
possono essere diverse.
E
e quindi per quei giorni, diciamo, in
cui magari non c'è altro,
sono sempre momenti, diciamo, andando
verso la fine della sessione in cui
m interpretandole nel modo giusto o
comunque sapendo della loro esistenza
e e come preprepararsi, tra virgolette,
eh sono occasioni anche lì per fare dei
bei trade.
spesso eh
non sempre nell'immediato. Allora,
cominciamo intanto a fare un po' di
ehm a prendere un po' di note. Allora,
ehm,
e facciamo un po' più grande,
quindi sono
ev Porca [\h__\h]
Quindi
e 20 volatilità
vola
ridotta.
Non sempre
le ehm
le analisi che ne attraiamo, comunque
gli insight che ne tiriamo fuori si
materializzano immediatamente, ma
possono darci ehm
qualche indicazione di conferma oppure
non di conferma su quella che è la
situazione generale. Ad esempio, se c'è
analizzando il livello di domanda per
una parte della curva particolare,
ehm, sì, andiamo a misurare la la la
insomma la ehm la situazione di di
salute di quello che è l'origine del
delle treasury. Noi tradiamo i derivati.
Ehm, non sempre noi tradiamo i i
derivati, ma qui stiamo parlando
dell'origine dei nostri prodotti.
Mercato primario. Adesso vediamo qui
cos'è. Non sempre si materializza
subito. Materializza
subito.
Allora,
intanto, che cos'è il debito? perché è
importante e
come funziona in linea di massima. Il
debito è importantissimo
perché è ciò che nei secoli ha permesso,
diciamo, uno sviluppo tecnologico sempre
più eh sempre più forte, l'innovazione,
eh la fondazione di ehm di stati eh che
quindi
è la è una promessa di pagamento perché
io oggi ho un progetto, io oggi ho un
bisogno di di finanziare un mio progetto
che io io ritengo
generare genererà del profitto, genererà
del benessere in un qualche tipo di
modo.
Tu che hai il denaro, prestamelo, io te
lo ripago m annualmente, semestralmente,
mensilmente,
fino all'estinzione del debito.
La stessa cosa vale per gli Stati.
Pensate che ci sono c'è il in Portogallo
c'è il museo del debito eh della moneta
o qualcosa del genere della tesoreria in
generale. Mi aveva fatto è andato un mio
amico che vive lì a a visitarlo e ci
sono delle dei bond, ci sono delle
obbligazioni
che pensate arrivano dalla città stato
di
Venezia o di Genova che sono datate tipo
1400.
ed erano semplicemente proprio delle
obbligazioni
ehm
che ehm
non mi ricordo più chi era, a chiedevano
i soldi, a qualche eh sovrano francese
o qualcosa del genere, no? Comunque
pensate quanto, cioè qua stiamo parlando
di 600 anni, ma esistevano addirittura
anche prima.
Arrivando ai giorni nostri esistono, ad
esempio, il Dipartimento del Tesoro
degli Stati Uniti che è fondamentalmente
il Ministero delle Finanze del governo
federale degli Stati Uniti d'America.
Ehm, la missione principale della
Treasury è
eh quella di gestire le finanze.
Quindi
eh gestisce le finanze.
Gestisce le finanze.
Anze scrivo come un cane. Non mi ostino
a fare queste whiteboard perché mi
piace. gestisce le finanze.
E questo include, quindi
le finanze includono, ci sono diversi
modi in cui arrivano le finanze.
Le tasse
principalmente in teoria il governo
dovrebbe finanziarsi
con le tasse,
il pagamento dei conti,
quello che altre parti devono allo Stato
e che lo Stato riscuote.
Eh, dopodiché gestisce
eh facciamo direttamente debito pubblico
pubblico
e fa da supervisione delle banche, ma
quello è un extra che fondamentalmente a
noi non interessa questa sua funzione,
ma ehm super fare la supervisione della
banca non so neanche, non mi ricordo
neanche in che modo. modo, ma mi sono
ripreso delle vecchie note che avevo
preso per fare questo e l'avevo segnato,
ma non ritengo importante perché non ho
mai notato ehm
un insomma negli anni, avete presente
quando si prendono delle note per
qualcosa che poi magari non ti
serviranno mai più. Ecco,
quando il governo spende più di quanto
incassa con le tasse, quindi ha un
deficit di bilancio,
il tesoro ha il compito di prendere in
prestito i fondi eh per coprire la
differenza.
Eh, indovinate un po', i governi girano
praticamente sempre in deficit perché le
tasse non sono mai abbastanza. è molto
ehm è molto rara questa occasione in cui
eh non c'è
non c'è deficit e anche se ci fosse ehm
preferiscono in ogni caso prendere un
qualcosa in più in prestito
per avere dell'extra.
Quindi fondamentalmente gira sempre del
del debito. Ehm, quando c'è deficit
deit, facciamo così,
deficit, ehm,
abbiamo
le asse del debito, quindi,
il che è molto bello per i mercati avere
una una cosa
una cosa simile.
Quando noi abbiamo ehm
appunto il del deficit federale,
deficit comunque di di stato vale per
qualsiasi paese al mondo. Ogni paese al
mondo ehm organizza delle asse del
debito. Ovviamente, se io sono gli Stati
Uniti d'America, non avrò alcuna
difficoltà ad ottenere dei finanziamenti
da da chiunque, da qualsiasi
partecipante al mercato. Adesso li
vedremo più nel dettaglio chi sono
quelli che partecipano al alle asse del
debito. Se invece io sono l'Argentina,
per non andare troppo lontani, dove il
governo è sempre instabile, piuttosto
che c'è un sacco di corruzione, avrò più
di più difficoltà.
Eh, se io sono un paese africano,
comunque del terzo mondo, avrò ancora
più difficoltà, ma comunque cercherò di
organizzare delle asse del debito,
quindi di prendere questi soldi. Asta
del debito semplicemente significa che
ehm
facciamo una bella classica casetta con
la borsa del denaro,
così diciamo. Quindi, ehm,
organizza asta.
Ast che tra virgolette
è un
è un diciamo Mi presti i soldi, per
favore?
dei soldi,
please.
Questa è l'asta, no? mi presti dei
soldi, please.
Eh, tanti partecipanti diversi
partecipano all'asta e io eh per farmi,
insomma, eh per farli partecipare io
offro del rendimento
che per loro è un rendimento, ma per me
è un costo. bisogna ricordarsi che eh
per chi ehm
diciamo compra questo debito ehm
è un rendimento, ma è un costo per la
banca centrale, no? dall'altro lato,
perché la banca centrale è vero che oggi
prende un miliardo di dollari, ma questo
miliardo di dollari intanto dopo dopo la
il periodo stabilito dovrà restituirlo
e ogni eh 6 mesi dovrà pagare un
rendimento. È annualizzato il tasso,
però viene pagato ogni 6 mesi.
Asta rendimento.
Il rendimento può variare, dipende
appunto dalla nostra bellissima ehm
curva dei rendimenti in base a dove si
trova un determinato tipo di ehm se noi
andiamo qui sul nostro
adesso ve lo posto qui. Se noi andiamo
sull'ex electronic monitor, l'economic
monitor, scusate, facciamo un bel view
mod interactive
e a seconda di ehm
Oggi abbiamo quelle a 6 mesi e quelle a
3 mesi che tanto piacciono in questo
periodo al
al Dipartimento della Tesoreria per una
serie di motivi.
M
sono alla fine di questi 6 mesi io ti
rido in soldi indietro e nel nel
frattempo vabbè adesso esempio stupido,
però ne se nel caso di 6 mesi, 3 mesi
non c'è un rendimento, ma c'è uno
sconto. Adesso vi spiego che cos'è. Eh,
però diciamo che se fosse una un'asta
del debito a 10 anni e insomma dove si
trova la curva dei rendimenti a 10 anni
in quel determinato momento, quello sarà
il rendimento dell'AS che poi eh non è
necessariamente quello esatto, può
variare leggermente,
dipende da qual è il rendimento massimo
che viene offerto poi all'asta ehm in
base a quella che è la domanda e
l'offerta al numero dei dei partecipanti
e quant'altro, il denaro che ehm che
partecipa all'assa viene determinato il
il rendimento, però può variare di poco,
però quel poco a noi serve per capire se
eh se c'era tanta domanda o meno
rispetto a all'offerta.
Ehm,
ok.
Questo diciamo che
va bene il debito comunque si per
ripetere il debito si origina per un per
tantissimi motivi. Allora il congresso,
nel caso degli USA approva delle una
tipologia di spese. Spendiamo in questo,
spendiamo in quell'altro. Adesso si
parla tanto delle spese militari che
sono una spesa gigantesca. Ovviamente il
settore militare porta innovazione. Ci
sono ovviamente ci sarà chi dirà che la
spesa militare è sbagliata, ma la spesa
militare porta anche innovazione. È
anche vero che dall'altra parte ci sono
i dissidenti che direbbero spendiamo per
altro. Io sono d'accordo. Ovviamente
dovrebbe essere un po' più equilibrata
la cosa, però dal punto di vista di di
chi governa noi non conosciamo appieno
il punto di vista, insomma, possiamo
dare giusto o sbagliato che sia. In ogni
caso, ehm, si fanno dei piani di eh di
spesa di spesa pubblica e in base a
questo piano di spesa pubblica il
congresso poi va dalla
dalla tesoreria, dice "Noi abbiamo
bisogno di questi soldi, ce li abbiamo
questi soldi, sì o no, son cazzi tuoi,
devi trovarli, devi trovarli in ogni
caso e noi dobbiamo averli perché
dobbiamo finanziare queste cose qua."
Ehm, vi dicevo prima che eh il oggi
c'era il QA, sarebbe il quarterly
refunding announcement che
fondamentalmente definisce ehm quanto
nel trimestre, quarterly trimestre, ehm
quanto nel trimestre la tesoreria
pianifica di eh di emettere in termini
di debito, quindi quanto deve emettere
in termini di AST. l'ultima volta che li
abbiamo avuti, adesso oggi è il
trimestre, ma poi in realtà arriva un
pochino in ritardo.
Ehm
ehm Sì, diciamo che ok, la parte teorica
iniziale l'abbiamo coperta, passiamo
direttamente a quello.
Eccolo qua.
Allora,
grande sti wide jets di di di bookmap
che
Allora, sì, intanto c'è esiste il sito
della USA Department, quello italiano
non ha più pallida idea di come si
chiama e di come presentino i dati, ma
non mi è mai interessato andare a
vedere. guarda solo i dati,
eventualmente quando trado i i bond
europei e mi interessa solo il dato, ma
neanche tanto, più che altro si si
tratta del tedesco, poi dipende.
Comunque
è stato rilasciato a
lunedì alle alle 15:00, anche oggi verrà
rilasciato probabilmente alle 3:00 loro,
quindi alle cos'è? alle 89 nostre,
quello che non è più tardi in realtà e
quello è anche un market perché in base
a quello che loro annunciano potrebbe
essere marketpo.
Ehm,
financing estimates,
giusto?
Ecco, esatto. Sì,
questo è il è un una parte del documento
del QA. Poi in realtà si va più nel
dettaglio, però comunque lì era per una
serie di motivi. L'ultima volta, quando
si parla del tetto del debito che va
aumentato, allora il debito intanto è
infinito, più che altro gli stati devono
essere lungimiranti nel non esagerare,
di non andare in sovrainditamento.
comunque devono generare del devono
essere in grado essere nella situazione
di continuare ad essere dei dei
buoni creditori, no? Quindi, eh
devono continuare a ripagare il debito
che già hanno,
devono comunque eh non esagerare con il
debito e poi esagerare, non esagerare
e è open to the budget, quindi dipende
dai punti di vista,
ma in ogni caso fondamentalmente possono
il debito può andare all'infinito ed è
giusto che sia così.
fondamentalmente
importante che il denaro giri in un
qualche modo, no? Quindi l'ultima volta
c'era stato un una un ritardo abbastanza
forte sul
sul sull'innalzamento del tetto del
debito perché non erano tutti quanti
d'accordo, insomma, se la tirano si si
tira per lunghe. Intanto se ci fosse uno
showdown
e ehm
e il tetto del debito, quindi adesso
abbiamo uno showdown, ma senza tetto del
debito, quindi senza che ci sia da
provare, insomma, anche quello.
Ma se dovesse capitare che gli Stati
Uniti vadano in showdown e ci sia anche
il tetto del debito da alzare e loro
quindi cominciano a saltare le rate, tra
virgolette,
ehm, vanno in default, quindi è
praticamente impossibile, no? però
diciamo che fa sempre un po' più eh
scalpore quando c'è un quando si rischia
lo showdown e quando c'è anche il delito
da da innalzare perché c'è il rischio,
insomma, abbastanza grande, percepito,
che poi insomma è solo per le testate
giornalistiche
che insomma vadano in default, no? Ovvio
che non non è possibile perché davvero
se dovesse capitare torneremo all'età
dellal della pietra. altro che fare
trading.
Eh, per quanto è intrinsecco comunque
quanto intrinsecamente tutto quanto si
basa sia sugli Stati Uniti, sulla loro
moneta e soprattutto sul loro debito per
via degli swap, per via degli stati
esteri che che investono. pensate
soltanto al Giappone che è uno dei più
grandi investitori in in treasury
americane, quelle quelle reali e
immaginate se gli Stati Uniti dovessero
andare in default vuol dire che anche
loro si ritrovano con senza soldi cui in
realtà loro pensano di avere, no? Così
come per tanti altri. Comunque un
groviglio infinito di cose che
conosciamo esploriamo, nel senso una
volta che voi lo sappiate potete
esplorare questo mondo all'infinito, ma
comunque la conoscenza che a noi
interessa è è limitata in confronto alla
estrema vastità che noi che che è quella
che questa tipologia di analisi
presenta, no?
Comunque vedete che ehm
durante luglio-settembre
la tesoreria si aspetta di prendere in
prestito un trilione di eh
in
privatric, nel senso che esporre la le
richiedere il debito sul sui mercati
privati,
ehm assumendo un un bilancio per fine
settembre sempre di 850 miliardi di
dollari, quindi un mese fa.
Fondamentalmente
il la stima del del del del numero è di
453 miliardi più alta rispetto a quanto
annunciato ad aprile per mh dovuto a eh
al bilancio disponibile più basso
rispetto a quanto proiettato.
Ehm
insomma poi durante ottobre e dicembre
che quindi oggi avremo la conferma
oppure no? Quindi già facevano una
proiezione eh su questo trimestre qui,
quindi
in quello in cui siamo attualmente,
altri 590 miliardi di in termini di
aste. Quindi, fondamentalmente quello
che stiamo aspettando oggi è un
riassunto di quello che è
di questo documento qua, no? di vedere
cosa cosa ne pensano adesso, anche
perché ora siamo nel durante uno
showdown, tante agenzie governative non
funzionano, ci sono un sacco di
problemi, fare delle stime è difficile,
quindi vedremo un po' cosa con cosa se
ne escono fuori. Ehm,
eccolo qua.
Mattina. Eh sì, adesso l'avevanno
rilasciato il 28, ma poi due giorni
dopo, quindi non so se stavolta sarà
esattamente uguale. Eh, due tra due
giorni, mercoledì ci sarà il documento
completo,
insomma. Poi in base a quello che loro
adesso qui hanno messo un trilione, poi
in base a quello stilano già una una
sottospecie di lista di quelle che sarà
il ciclo delle asse del tesoro e quindi
daranno più peso a solitamente vabbè la
maggior parte di questi miliardi e
stramiliardi
viene messa in treasury bills di varia
natura, quindi tutto quel debito ehm
tutti quei prodotti che sono al di sotto
dell'anno di durata, no? Abbiamo
scadenze fino a un anno, quindi abbiamo
le TBills.
Aspetta, passiamo qua. Abbiamo le TBS.
Facciamo direttamente le grandi
categorie TBills che noi forse non
abbiamo ehm
non abbiamo mai coperto. Abbiamo 4 8 13
26 52 settimane,
eh.
Sì, 8. No, in realtà sono quattro. Tipo
oggi c'abbiamo la six week.
Aspettate che sto andando a memoria.
Te
oggi c'è quella 6 mesi. Comunque sì, mi
pare che siano poi verifichiamo aggiorno
a caso. Eh,
dove cazzo è finito la filma qua?
Nope. Eccolo qua.
Quindi c'abbiamo queste.
Ehm, come abbiamo detto prima, sono
emesse a sconto. Che cosa vuol dire che
sono emesse a sconto? le messe a sconto,
quindi non hanno un rendimento, quindi
se esce una TBIL a al 4% non è quel 4%
non è ehm non è l'interesse, quindi non
pagano interessi periodici,
ma il rendimento deriva dalla differenza
tra pezzo d'acquisto e valore e il
valore nominale a chiusura a scadenza,
scusate. Quindi se oggi vale eh se io
l'ho comprata che il prezzo era ad
esempio eh acquisto un TB 6 mesi per
$98.50 50
ehm
ricevo $100 alla scadenza per dire, no,
se il prezzo fosse quello o un
rendimento del 3% in quel periodo.
Comunque dipende dal prezzo e quindi
facendo poi la differenza anche dell'IMM
Index, quindi è come avevamo detto che
le TBills solitamente sono quotate in
prezzo 100 meno il prezzo, come abbiamo
i software, i fed funds e così via.
abbiamo il 100 meno il prezzo e quindi
si ricava in quel modo poi il il
rendimento.
Eh l'utilizzo delle TBills sono solo, eh
generalmente questi prodotti qui,
specialmente quelli real, no? Quindi
mercato reale non derivato, non a leva,
viene utilizzato principalmente per
gestioni delle liquidità tipo conto
termine, eh corto termine e investimenti
sicuri per
amministrare il denaro in eccesso così
via, no? Insomma è un una tipologia di
prodotto particolare mirata ehm
fondamentalmente verso i grandi fondi
monetari. le grandi banche o comunque
banche che hanno tanta liquidità e così
via.
Poi abbiamo le Treasury notes, le T
notes
che sono le nostre belle due, scusate,
andiamo le nostre 2 5 10.
Eh, poi in realtà abbiamo anche i
Scusate, facciamo, aspetta,
abbiamo anche i sette. In realtà gli
scalioni sono di più perché poi dipende
7 10 ci sono anche i eh non so se i 15
ripartono ancora nei
nei notes. No, non mi pare. Abbiamo ehm
pagano e quindi loro pagano invece
cedole semestrali a tasso fisso. Pagano
cedole semestrali
semestrali a tasso fisso.
Tasso.
Attenzione, queste sono quelle nominali
che quindi in realtà il rendimento reale
è un altro, ma adesso ci arriviamo.
Perché dico vabbè perché dico eh
rendimento nominale? Perché se io sono
eh un fondo comunque qualcuno che
mh
più hai denaro più cose come
l'inflazione impattano il tuo denaro
perché vale sempre di meno e senti di
più la differenza, no?
Non che se uno ne ha ne meno sente meno
un'inflazione ovviamente, però se io ho
un rendimento a 10 anni di del 4%
>> in realtà non è 4% per davvero e
il 4% meno l'inflazione attuale, quella
dell'anno prossimo, quella dell'anno
prossimo ancora, quindi man mano erode,
erode erode. L'inflazione erole tutto,
no? L'inflazione è inarrestabile,
esattamente come tendenzialmente la
crescita.
Ehm
e quindi man mano andando avanti il il
tasso reale che io ho incasso dai c
insomma non sarà mai il 4%, no?
Poi abbiamo i Tbons.
Devo verificare, non mi ricordo se i 15
sono, anche perché esiste anche il 15,
ma vabbè. Ehm,
ma no, ma forse del 15 non c'è neanche
l'ast, non vale la pena. Non c'è di
sicuro l'ast del 15. È solo che
ad esempio workspace ve lo riporta, ma
soltanto tra i ticker perché ovviamente
nel momento in cui questo 10 anni è è
uscito questo, no? Diciamo abbiamo un 10
che è uscito 5 anni fa,
fa al
5%, per così dire, no?
Oggi in realtà è un 5 anni, quindi
insomma va avanti nel tempo. Quindi ehm
nel momento in cui nel momento in cui
stesso in cui del debito esce comincia a
scadere il tempo, no? Per quello,
aspetta, finiamo solo questo, poi vi
dico. Eh, scadenza abbiamo 2030 anni,
quindi si traglucono in ZB e UB
fondamentalmente. Poi per i futurous il
calcolo è molto molto diverso. Quindi
per i TBills
in questa categoria
rientrano
anche i software,
cioè insomma che racchiudono questa
parte. Eh, cioè in realtà non è proprio
giusto dire così,
eh no, che poi vi metto confusione. TBS
sono TBS, non c'entra niente, era solo
per abbinarvi il prodotto, no? Quindi
quando abbiamo quando parliamo di
scadenze corte abbiamo ad esempio anche
il tasso software, però non è che la
tesoreria fa uscire il un debito che si
chiama software, quindi non non
mettiamo così, però era giusto per
perché qua invece nelle Totes abbiamo
abbiamo
ZT il nostro 2 anni, abbiamo ZF il
nostro 5 anni Giusto per fare chiarezza,
abbiamo il 7 anni che è ZN. Attenzione,
attenzione,
Zen non è 10 anni.
E poi abbiamo TN, il l'ultra 10 anni che
invece tra e diciamo come scadenza
abbiamo mi pare un anno e mezzo. Ehm,
adesso per non scrivere cagate, però
comunque abbiamo tra un anno e mezzo e
tre, poi c'è tutta una convenzione che
si chiama Chipest to Deliver, a cui
arriveremo più tardi. Eh, questo
racchiude tra i 4 e i 6 anni, qualcosa
del genere. Comunque sono poi hanno
delle finesse temporali. Zen, che me lo
ricordo bene che ad esempio 7 anni 7
anni e mezzo eh 9 anni e mezzo o 7 anni
9 anni e mezzo eh di come finestra
temporale
e poi abbiamo il TN che invece è proprio
quello stretto e abbiamo 9 anni e mezzo
10, quindi è quello più preciso, però in
ogni caso si usa il ZN come benchmark
comunque, no? Ehm,
asate cheesco avanti con le note, che
magari l'ho scritto, non spiegate.
Ehm,
no, non l'avevo scritto, giusto?
Allora, poi abbiamo Tibons e abbiamo ZB
che è nostro 20 anni, però in realtà
racchiude tra i 15 e i 25, ma questo
comunque lo possiamo
eh verificare immediatamente se uno va
sul sito group,
non su quick strike, ma semplicemente
si group. Andiamo sul sito CMI, si può
verificare tranquillamente con la
precisione se uno va sulla scheda del
prodotto,
Zen carica, cioè Zem Group carica sempre
bene la prima pagina, però in realtà
dopo
ehm
Dove stava
US Treasury Futures Treasury Notes con
una eh una un tempo alla scadenza di
almeno 6 anni e mezzo, ma meno di 8,
quindi in realtà è ancora più
Se noi andiamo su TN vedrete che sono
più ehm
ultra TN così me lo trovi. Ti piace?
Eccolo qua. Io l'ultra tener di not
futures. TN è un prodotto che è un po'
così, diciamo che esattamente come l'UB
sono meno liquidi, più sweepy, quindi
saltellano un po' di più a destra e a
sinistra. Ehm,
almeno 9 anni e mezzo, ma non non più di
10, comunque è più stretto, vedete? Non
so perché mi era rimasto in testa 7 anni
e mezzo, 9 anni e mezzo, comunque
evidentemente mi sbagliavo. E 6 anni e
mezzo e 8 anni Zen, molto stretto, molto
più vicino a ZF in realtà di quanto di
quanto lo sia verso i 10 anni.
TN, dicevo, è uno di quei prodotti come
l'UB sulla tesoreria che sono quelli
meno puri, eh, più eh, scusate, che
cazzo cerca di nuovo? Ehm,
come dire, è vero che ha meno liquidità
ed è più sweepy, in teoria
porta anche più facilmente denaro, più
facile ad entrare,
ehm, ma
non ha un orderflow puro, quindi è
sempre sempre comunque da utilizzare ehm
basandosi su una analisi
che deriva, che deve deve derivare da
suo fratello maggiore in termini di eh
volumi eh e liquidità che è lo Zen. Se
io diciamo se io sono una persona, un
trader che ha un po' di esperienza e
conosco bene Zen e riesco già a diciamo
a ehm
a a concentrarmi su più di un mercato
per volta, no?
scusate, a concentrarmi su un più di un
mercato per volta, ce li ho di fianco
uno l'altro in fila e se io vedo un
segnale eh la mia entry su Zen, ma
riesco anche a percepire che troppo
tardi per ottenere un buon prezzo
comunque di essere fillati senza il
rischio di dare via legge, ehm,
posso operare sul TN, ma questo
deveniene molto molto dopo, molto dopo
rispetto a prenderli e tradarli da soli.
Cioè, stessa cosa vale per Lubi. Lui B,
ovviamente l'UB è il prodotto dove van a
finire, abbiamo ne abbiam già parlato,
ma poi lo ripeto, non mi interessa. L'UB
è quello dove vanno parare tutti coloro
che arrivano dai dalle equities
direttamente.
È vero che che paga, però non si impara
a tradare la tesoreria su UB. Insomma, è
un è una tipologia di trading che poi
quando non funziona
ritorni sul su da dove da dove sei
partito, quindi ritorni ad avere i
problemi che avevi prima, perché se uno
di solitamente
passa dalla
dalle equities a alla tesoreria, tante
volte è perché mi dice io ho problemi
con le equities perché è troppo un
roller coaster di emozioni, no? Quindi
anche nel PNL
invece poi ovviamente c'è chi integra
chi vuole integrare il suo bagaglio di
conoscenze di prodotti e quello eh
assolutamente però poi sai Rub non è il
massimo. tantissime persone che che
conosco sono arrivate dalle da
dell'equitis, sono andate sui Ubigli è
andato bene per 3 mesi, poi sono
cambiate le condizioni ulteriormente
se la sono presa di dietro in ogni caso
sono tornato su equity sapendo altre
batost equity. Comunque ehm
qui siamo su ZF su F yearne
e qui abbiamo eh non più di 5
anni e 3 mesi e non meno di 4 anni e e 2
mesi.
Ecco il fatto.
Quindi molto vicino Zien in realtà ai
cinque labelli.
Ehm,
quindi comunque
abbiamo tutta la nostra bella curva,
immaginiamo però
eh vista
in questo modo qui. Abbiamo la nostra
bella curva, abbiamo
prendiamola, vabbè dai, prendiamola così
e abbiamo il front.
Diamo anche una definizione precisa.
Belli
back,
così si chiamano scadenze corte. Abbiamo
il front, le scadenze intermedie,
abbiamo il belly. Fondamentalmente il
belly e ZN, no? NTN
rientrano nella nella belli un pochino
anche, insomma, fanno da da punto
centrale e poi abbiamo il back che sono
ZB e UB.
Poi allora
abbiamo coperto questa cosina qui.
Ehm,
sarebbe da parlare delle strips, però le
strips non ci interessano proprio per
niente, nel senso non ne ho non ne
utilizzo per niente e e praticamente si
smembrano le i bond, ma lì non ci
interessa. Se volete andare a vedere che
cosa sono le strips, sono separate
trading of registered interest and
principal securities,
ehm,
andate a vedere comunque cosa sono gli
strips, se mi interessa.
Allora,
m
io direi che abbiamo parlato del QA,
che è quello dove viene annunciato per
il trimestre,
ehm,
il piano, insomma, e bisogna anche
ricordarsi, prima ne ho fatto una nota
che ehm
essere sempre a deficit nel bilancio
significa che a me mancano i soldi. pure
per ripagare i vecchi debiti.
Per quello si chiama ehm
refunding perché loro perché si tratta
di rifinanziare anche del debito
precedente, no? Quindi questo denaro non
solo viene usato per pagare le
operazioni di governo, quel che
vogliamo, ma anche e in gran parte,
anche se vogliamo dire per rifinanziare
il vecchio debito. C'è un grande
problema, non cioè problema che devono
eh Trump l'aveva ne aveva parlato anche,
l'avrete sentito sicuramente, no? quando
diceva che voleva che Powell
assolutamente tagliasse perché lui non
vuole più pagare il debito vecchio a ai
tassi che avevano bloccato quando erano
altissimi, no? Quindi quando è stati
mantenuti
alti per così tanto, anziché venire
abbassati, insomma, c'erano motivi, no,
per carità, però perché poi io se la
tesoreria oggi emette comunque 2 anni fa
e ha messo del del debito al 5%
a
sui sulle sulle scadenze tipo dei 10-5
anni, vuol dire che adesso, nonostante
che i tassi siano scesi, loro comunque
devono pagare non stop quella quantità,
no, di eh di rendimento. Quello rimane
uguale. Per quello, se durante periodi
in cui i tassi di interesse sono alti è
un po' un dito in culo, possiamo
tranquillamente chiamarlo per la
tesoreria perché ehm perché poi sanno
che dopo un
hanno bisogno di denaro comunque sempre,
magari anche di più perché ci sono
determinati tipi di problemi, ma poi gli
costerà molto di più. Per quello poi i
l'accelerazione magari del eh ci sono
delle accelerazioni nella nell'aumento
dei del debito pubblico e quindi viene
maggiorato ancora di più il il deficit
eh nel tempo per per via di questi
periodi, no?
Ehm,
bene. Allora, io direi che vabbè,
intanto fino adesso ci sono domande. Io
come sempre vado sempre un po' sparso,
però se avete qualcosa non è chiaro,
gran parte delle cose le dico a memoria,
quindi poi mi viene in mente qualcosa la
dico perché poi però avete domande
sparate, per favore.
Io tutto chiaro, va bene?
>> Grazie.
Grazie. Va bene. Allora, ehm,
interessante fino adesso vi interessano
queste cose, anche se non è proprio
pratica pura.
Eh, spero che comunque anche se facciamo
delle cose che poi non sono pratiche
pratiche, comunque noi la teoria
sottostante per arrivare poi a eh come
utilizziamo i dati sull'assa, diciamo,
per misurare ehm lo stato comunque di
salute un po' della curva del dei
rendimenti
e anche poi di trarre vantaggio saper
leggere un'assa del debito per farci
quell'ultimo trade della giornata.
Comunque è necessario capire un pochino
come come cosa stiamo guardando, no?
>> Io preferisco avere la teoria perché
così riesco a capire meglio la pratica.
Certo.
Allora, quindi il quarter di refunding
announcement, comunque
il quarter facciamo una una nota,
facciamo si vengono vengono fatte le
stime di finanziamento,
quindi quanto pensano di dover prendere
a debito finanziamento.
vengono, insomma, ehm
dati dei dettagli su delle dei dettagli
sulle aste, quindi su quale parte della
della curva si concentreranno, no? Ma
solitamente sono sempre TBills,
specialmente nell'ultimo periodo, perché
tagli delle aste
è ovvio che ehm essendo che le T bills a
scadenza cortissima sono denaro più
sicuro, no? perché mi permettono la
flessibilità e di,
insomma, è vero che
c'è il rischio del prezzo e tutto qu di
tutte quelle cose lì, ma in ogni caso
ehm
sono un parcheggio, tra virgolette, un
investimento a breve termine sicuro. E
stiamo parlando comunque di di quelli
che muovono il denaro reale, no? quelli
che poi eh per effetto indiretto
regoleranno la liquidità disponibile nei
nostri portafogli o comunque per le
aziende
sono sempre più appetibili per loro
perché vuol dire che avranno più
possibilità di muoversi, no? mentre
invece ovviamente ci sarà sempre eh
un'offerta minore di debito e dunque
anche di domanda di debito a 30 anni.
Cioè pensate che addirittura
eh l'Italia
si ferma molto prima o comunque le asse
del debito eh sono
molto più ridotte rispetto agli USA, no?
Eh anche se le nostre situazioni
economiche non sono poi così diverse,
insomma. Però, ad esempio, i future
sulla
ehm sui BTP
si fermano a poco oltre, cioè per loro
lungo termine per i BTP per l'Eurex è 10
anni, no? Quindi reputano 10 anni per
l'Italia eh lungo termine, no? L'FBTP
normale è copre poco più dei 10 anni.
FBT,
vabbè, pari di due, insomma, è quello
più liquido, quello che si muove di
meno, esattamente come
il 2 anni invece italiano, proprio per
questa strettezza, sembra quasi un
software per come per come si
distribuisce la liquidità e il volume.
Vi consiglio di dare un'occhiata
a BTP, se vi capitasse,
eh, di avere i dati dell'Eurex, di dare
un'occhiata al Bond, all'FBTP, a UAT e
tutte ste cose qua sono super bellissimi
come mercati, molto diversi, ma comunque
belli. è, diciamo, uno stadio un po' più
avanzato delle dei de treasuries perché
abbiamo dati più limitati su quei
mercati lì, meno tool, è un po' più
difficile, sono un po' più sconosciuti
perché per quanto noi siamo europei e
abbiamo l'Eurex che è è un exchange
bellissimo, no? addirittura ha
introdotto il trading elettronico sui
future molto prima, diciamo, è diventato
popolare prima su sull'Eurex rispetto
alla CMI addirittura, no? Eh, quindi è
super all'avanguardia, c'è dei il
i data center di dell'Eurex, quelli eh
Monaco e Francoforte, mi pare che
Francoforte sia il più grande, eh, gli
dà gli dà merda al ad Aurora. Auroraa o
come cacchio si chiama? Aurora, il data
center della CMI a Chicago. Eh, a no,
non è non è non mi ricordo comunque il
paese, comunque lì vicino a Chicago, un
uno che conosco è andato a vederlo da
fuori, una cosa gigantesca,
mastodontica,
comunque quello lì fra forte tanta roba.
Eh, però in ogni caso, pur essendo che
noi siamo europei, abbiamo abbiamo tutti
questi bellissimi prodotti,
siamo comunque abituati per popolarità a
tradare eh i mercati americani, perché
poi uno inizia con le equities, magari
passa ai
future eccetera, ma sempre rimanendo
sulla CMI e si dimentica un po'
dell'Europa, cioè non fa figo a nessuno,
direi "Io trado l'Eurostocks, cioè
Oppure [risate]
anche se uno fa equities, se uno tra
dell FSX dell'Eurostocks
50 il mercato è fantastico. C'hai
300-400 lotti per livello, un orderflow
da paura perché è veramente puro e
sembra Yes prima del 2020. Nel 2020 l'IS
l'ha rovinato in termini di qualità del
future, no? Entre il FSX è rimasto così
e poi per chi volesse aggiungere c'
avete l'FVS che è ehm il Vstocks la
volatilità sull'Eurostocks e c'è il
future ed è direttamente sull'Eurex e
c'è una bella strategia. Questo
parentesi, c'è una bella strategia che
funzionava almeno un annetto fa
funzionava, poi non ho più tradato più
di tanto l'FSX, qualcuno mi dice che
ancora ci sta.
Ehm a volte e per via dell'arbitraggio,
di quel che vogliamo, dell'adattamento
del eh del del VOX sottostante all FVS,
a volte dà il movimento prima,
ovviamente sempre opposto al all'FSX,
quindi magari eh l'FVS svende e hai quei
510 secondi per entrare anche a mercati
in una posizione sull'F. FSX e fare
qualche tic, cioè protsi che funzioni
ancora, ma comunque sono belli. Ehm, e
poi vabbè, sì, è una strategia generale
e sempre dove devo chiedere poi a a
Federico se ha testa di ritagliarle bene
tutte ste cose perché io non c'ho testa
e e fare dei ritagli
generale.
ehm
possono annunciare, ad esempio, eh
dei cambiamenti particolari nella loro
strategia, ad esempio, su eh nell'ultimo
Qay o quello che era avevano annunciato
che avrebbero eh aumentato un po' la
e qua ci ricolleghiamo un'altra cosa
importante e avrebbero aumentato le
dissuance, quindi Quindi la l'emissione
del debito sui tips. Ricordate prima
abbiamo parlato del fatto che
dell'inflazione che erode il mio
rendimento, la Treasury emette
direttamente i ehm eh Treasury Inflation
Protected Securities, quindi sono
direttamente
eh delle delle obbligazioni
che incorporano già l'inflazione con
delle stime molto precise e prendono il
rendimento, esempio, del 10 anni al
momento della dell'emissione dell'asta
e eh sottraggono l'inflazione stimata
per, diciamo, l'anno prossimo, quello il
periodo in generale, non mi ricordo qual
è il calcolo preciso e ed escono
direttamente con eh
quello che deve essere il rendimento
reale, no?
Dai tips che incorporano quindi tutti i
calcoli sull'infrazione derivano poi i
break even inflation rate. Break even
inflation rate sono fondamentalmente
delle stime abbastanza accurate perché
vengono basate sui tips che quindi
incorporano il calcolo super preciso e
fantastico della stima dell'inflazione.
Incorporano questa stima e ti dicono tra
5 anni la stima sull'infrazione
basandosi sui tips è questa. Quindi eh
se se l'accelerazione è più marcata, se
è molto più alta, ehm ci sono i tips sui
cinque, sui 10
eh ufficiali, intendo. Aspetta,
guardiamo su Google direttamente.
Allora, allora, allora, allora, ecco
qua, abbiamo il tips e abbiamo i 5 e 10,
il 30, eh, basta. 5, il 10, il 30
c'abbiamo di tips
in realtà, che è una cosa fastidiosa, ma
sia Bloomberg che Refinitive hanno del
reverse engineering
per calcolare il break even inflation
rate anche sulle scadenze un anno, 2
anni, 3 anni. Ehm,
ecco qua. Vediamo un attimo perché
questo e perevo colpa di sti widget di
di book, ma però non c'ho voglia di
chiuderlo. C'ho devo mettermi a
fare eh i giochetti. Allora, ehm,
eh
one year break.
Perché non mi puoi caricare? Facciamo
direttamente una pagina nuova. Tu va
via.
Eh,
US Bay era qua, vedete? L'USBay
One Year, ad esempio, non esiste, non
potrebbe esistere, non avrebbe ragione
di esistere il One Year, ma ehm hanno
fatto reverse engineering del dei
calcoli e ne derivano i anche quelli a
un anno, 2 anni, 3 anni che ci stava
perché ehm
era un'indicazione extra, insomma un
dato extra che incorporava già un sacco
di cose sulle aspettative di inflazione,
soprattutto dopo determinati tipi di
eventi, no? Eh, però non c'è più, non
c'è neanche non ci sono perché erano
offerti dalla Trade Web e noi Trade Web
non ce l'abbiamo più come fornitore di
dati che Trade Web e Brokertech sono eh
Allora, Trade Web sono due sono due
broker ehm
statut intensi più grandi per quanto
riguarda la tesoreria. Brokertech,
ovviamente lo dice lo stesso nome, è un
è un dealer, un eh inter, cioè
Sì, è un dealer inter broker,
interfirms, interfondi monetari, insomma
fa da da centrale mercato della
tesoreria è OTC. Cosa significa OTC? che
ehm non è centralizzato, non ha un
orderbook centralizzato. Possiamo essere
io,
David, eh fondo monetario che ha 100
miliardi di dollari e vado da Manuele
fond fondo monetario da 500 miliardi di
dollari con le mie Treasury e noi
facciamo un accordo tra di noi, tra
virgolette, ce le scambiamo, no? Vabbè,
per dirla, no? Quindi non c'è un una
cosa una cosa centrale, però il
brokertech comunque facilita, ci sono in
ogni caso, pur essendo over the counter
per natura. In realtà non è proprio così
perché ehm
anche gli stessi partecipanti al mercato
preferiscono che ci sia della
controparte che assicura sia da un lato
che dall'altro che i fondi ci siano, che
questo che sia tutto a posto e quindi in
realtà si avvalgono di eh di
intermediare in ogni caso. Per esempio
la Brokertech è una di quelli.
Comunque Trade Web invece faceva da fa
da broker, da da dealer anche per i
privati e fornivano i dati estremamente
accurati, molto belli, però la LSG ce li
ha tolti. Adesso, in questi giorni, in
realtà ehm
stanno lottando per riaverli di nuovo
per la quarta o quinta volta che ci
riproviamo. Ehm,
a che cosa non ho risposto, Emy?
Stavo leggendo adesso il commento.
In ogni caso ce l'hanno tolto, ma
vediamo se ce lo ridanno. In ogni caso
vediamo, vediamo un po' come va a
finire. Non è la prima volta che
facciamo, ma questa volta è partito Rob
a razzo, che è un ex
eh
cliente che ha usato sia la versione
Xinit che quella vera e non ho capito
bene se ha un contatto e si è cominciato
a lamentare da paura. Io ho registrato
dei video per spiegargli esattamente
cos'è che ci manca e vediamo cosa
rispondono gli stronzi.
Eh sì, questo tutto ciò per dire che
vedete Sì, per i tips, no? Il Treasury
inflation protected securities
e abbiamo direttamente un
un prodotto che già incorpora
direttamente l'infrazione, per cui era
bello anche non solo da da non è bello
anche non è bello solo d essere tradato,
ma anche per farci delle analisi sopra.
molto molto interessante. Ehm, sono
andato avanti e vi ho detto già cosa dei
tips. Aspettate che sicuramente mi sono
perso qualcosa.
Ehm m
No, direi che andiamo possiamo anche
cominciare ad andare a vedere come
funziona per più preciso.
Basta.
Sì.
Eh, per avere il dato sul
sul sui avete ad esempio
questo cosa ci dà?
To expected inflation. Che cos'è di
bello?
Interessante. L'avevo già cercata sta
roba, però non mi ricordo. Comunque su
Fred c'è
l'infrazione attesa
e ovviamente rilasciano il dato un mese
per mese.
Quando lo rilasciano? Il 24 di ottobre.
Il 24 di ottobre quanto è stato l'ultimo
dato? 2.51.
Comunque abbiamo il il 10 year ehm
break even inflation rate che misura che
quindi teoricamente da qui a 10 anni ha
voglia, però come lo leggiamo m se si
abbassa
e in generale significa che eh
l'aspettativa inflazionistica è più
bassa. Se si alza
viceversa, no? E comunque è in è
un'indicazione di di anche se è quello a
10 year. Ehm abbiamo anche il
meno anche 5 anni se abbiamo un po' più
di precisione, no? Ehm
è abbastanza stabile, no? da un bel po'
di tempo che è abbastanza stabile, a
parte delle spike.
Ehm,
vedete che è abbastanza ritardo. Qua era
al top, ovviamente al top
dell'infrazione, cioè del
dell'inflazione in generale, quella
reale, quella che abbiamo avuto, abbiamo
avuto anche il top qua, quindi sono
abbastanza da prendere con le pinze, le
cose. Per quello io preferivo quello a
ad esempio a un anno, 2 anni, però
comunque sappiate che esiste che deriva
dal calcolo dei tips.
E poi poi poi direi che questa parte
abbiamo il Five on fives. Questo ci
arriveremo un'altra volta oppure più
tardi. E
prendiamo un'occhiata cosa è successo di
bello.
Eh,
bellino.
Ho fatto 10 12 tic prima della
paio d'ore.
Va bene. Eh, vado un attimo in bagno e
arrivo. 5 minuti, ragazzi.
Eccomi.
Io sono qui, non so gli altri.
>> Ma Emy, che cos'è? Che cos'è che ho ha
detto Emy che non ho risposto?
>> No, avevo Ah no, ti risponde lei che ha
porto microfono.
>> No, vabbè che dicevo che io preferisco
pure la teoria
perché così riesco a capire anche meglio
la pratica.
Ah beh, certo, certo. No, ma è giusto
che sia così,
però bisogna anche fare pratica, è il
primo possibile anche mettere le mani in
pasta.
però questo mercato dove probabilmente
salti la parte
c schifo riman con l'incif in mano
perché è completamente diverso, cioè non
completamente diverso magari le
dinamiche di Lord Flow, però devi
comprendere dove stia mettendo le mani e
capire anche le dinamiche economiche che
vi sono dietro è troppo importante.
Sì, assolutamente.
Ok, allora
ma non è Vabbè, non dico niente perché
c'avevo uno short che ho chiuso tipo per
due tic con tre lotti. Guarda, tenerlo.
Vabbè. Ehm,
allora,
appunto, prima accennavo sul fatto di eh
di rifinanziare il debito, si chiama,
diciamo, ehm,
vabbè, rifinanziamento
ovviamente, ma possiamo chiamarlo anche
il ehm
rollover debito.
Lover del debito, che è il meccanismo
per il quale eh ogni ogni totò di tempo,
addirittura anche ogni giorno,
ehm
c'è del debito che scade, no? Magari c'è
del debito che è stato emesso 20 anni fa
e scade oggi, no? E quindi quel debito
che hanno che è stato messo 20 anni fa,
oggi la teroseria deve mettere le mani
alle tasche e ripagarlo. La stessa cosa
ovviamente vale per le scadenze più
corte, quindi continue, quelle più
sensibili al cambiamento eh dei tassi
che piacciono a a tutti quanti perché
sono più flessibili e è proprio per
quello piacciono di più e quindi ci sarà
più domanda, sarà più facile prendere i
soldi sul corto termine alla alla
tesoreria, ma allo stesso tempo è un un
cane che si morde la coda perché c'è
rischio che dovranno ripagare un sacco
di debito per tanto tempo, no? per
diverso tempo, eh, magari siamo arrivati
a dei tassi altissimi
in questo ciclo di quantitative
tightening, no? Tutto quel debito che è
stato emesso a 5 anni, 10 anni, magari
tra 5 anni la situazione dei tassi sarà
a posto, sarà tutto sotto controllo, no?
sai, un bel periodo in cui è tutto ok,
però loro si ritroveranno a dover
ripagare, continuare a ripagare del
debito magari al 5%
continuazione, quando in realtà quei in
quel periodo poi saranno magari al 2 e
mezzo tre, no?
Quindi, ehm,
cioè il si chiama il rischio di
rifinanziamento.
Aumento.
Ehm,
che è quello che che che vi ho appena
detto, no?
Poi abbiamo ehm
diciamo che hanno un meccanismo che per
me da nella precisione è completamente
eh sconosciuto, nel senso non mi sono
mai addentrato. Questa dinamica qua del
rollover del debito sappiamo che c'è,
sappiamo che crea problemi, sappiamo che
in determinati periodi crea più problemi
di altri. Se volete approfondire,
comunque, ehm, basta ricercarlo in un
qualche modo e e lo trovate.
M però abbiamo anche il maturity profile
che fondamentalmente
tutte le decisioni ovviamente della
tesoreria
che vengono fatte sono fatte
strategicamente, quindi si viene eh
vanno a
creare, diciamo,
eh un bilanciamento, vanno a bilanciare
il costo del finanziamento con il
rischio di rollover eh in modo tale da
non fare una concentrazione eccessiva di
scadenze a breve termine per non esporsi
maggiormente a rischio di tasso, cosa
che adesso vedremo
forse stanno un pochino facendo adesso,
perché quei
poi l'ho fatto vedere anche l'altra
volta quando dico aste da capogiro,
stiamo parlando di aste da 100 miliardi
di dollari in continuazione.
su scadenze brevissime.
Eh, poi abbiamo anche
la UV, com'è che si chiamava? la
one oited
average maturity. Quindi loro hanno una
stima di della media in base appunto
ponderata su anche quanto è stato
emesso, quanto hanno offerto,
ehm di qual è la loro maturity media,
quindi la loro scadenza media, insomma.
Ehm,
bene.
Oltre al QRA, che è quello trimestrale,
abbiamo anche
nel dettaglio che poi il QRA è un piano,
ma abbiamo poi l'MTS
e DTS. Questo sembra un H. L'MTS e DTS.
Questo è il Montly Treasury Statement,
quindi è il documento con cui dicionano
di quanto sono sovrainditati,
di di quale è il loro il il bilancio
della dei fondi della tesoreria e c'è
anche il Daily Treasury Statement che è
quello giornaliero.
Ehm,
sono qui, ve faccio vedere giusto per
farvi capire,
eh.
Questo è un altro sito, il tre fiscal
data.
Eh,
treg direct. Questo è dove reperisco la
API per fare le
dove caspita stava MTS DTS?
Devo trovarle, perché voglio farvelo un
po' più vedere.
No, forse non è proprio quella data.
Forse se vado Ah, cazzo, l'ho visto.
Ah!
Eccolo qua il montre statements.
Allora, l'avevo già scaricato prima per
far vedere, no?
Eccolo qua. Vabbè,
allora
vabbè, senza andare nel dettaglio,
il mese scorso, l'ultimo rilascio che
c'è stato, il final budget risulta
e dettagli che ha un deficit di 1.775
trilioni di dollari, migliaia di
miliardi di dollari.
per cumulativo per l'anno 2025, cioè
stiamo parlando di di cifre assurde, no?
Non soitiamoci, no? Eh, ma finché il
castello regge, adesso vi faccio anche
vedere come fa il castello a reggere.
Va bene, allora
vediamo. Spostiamoci un po' più di un
po' più sotto.
Allora, come va a funzionare una option
au? Allora,
option
o perché è asta.
Ehm, allora
il Dipartimento della Tesoreria decide
la data dell'asta viene aggiunta
viene stimata, ma viene poi annunciata e
confermata eh da 3 a 5 giorni prima la
data precisa. L'orario è sempre lo
stesso. Si tratta di un'asta
elettronica.
Ah, elettronica. Sì, elettronica.
è un'asta elettronica, ovviamente molto
molto molto rapida,
dura circa
2 minuti,
quindi quando voi vedete l'asta è alle
19, ehm, in realtà il risultato arriva
alle 19:02 e qualcosa, quindi dura circa
2 minuti, insomma, poi dipende da quanto
è facile o meno concludere. La dipende
dai partecipanti quanto sono rompiballe
sul rendimento che vogliono ottenere.
Ehm,
dura circa 2 minuti. Quelle più
frequenti sono adesso lo vediamo anche
andiamo su Xenit va direttamente così.
Le più frequenti sono quelle a corto
termine
perché mi devono rendere vita difficile.
Se voi andate qua c'avete il
Oh, ma sei stronzo.
Ecco, Government Dept Actions, AST del
debito governativo
e avete eh gli ultimi 30 giorni, ad
esempio, se volete vedere quelle
passate,
dovete mettere gli ultimi 30 giorni, gli
ultimi 7 giorni, mettere una data
precisa, mettere la recints oppure
upcoming auctions vi dirà quando sono le
prossime, quindi se volete ad esempio
aggiungervela al calendario così
Ovviamente sono segnati.
Che tipologia?
Eh, mettere tutti e tre e avete Allora,
non abbiamo avuto nessuno dei 30 anni.
Abbiamo avuto
oggi, abbiamo appena avuta, è già
passato, son perso. Abbiamo avuto quella
a 6 mesi, vedete? 80 miliardi di dollari
in a 6 mesi, 90 miliardi di dollari a 3
mesi. Eh, bit to cover 2.62 2.92, adesso
vedremo che cos'è, ma misura ehm la
domanda che c'è rispetto all'offerta.
ehm
nella nel nell'asta eh quelle a un mese
che sono quelle che hanno sempre di più.
Vedete 110 miliardi, abbiamo un 110
miliardi anche qua sono sempre eh è
sempre quella a un mese, no? sono fisse.
Una volta che viene definito abbastanza
il piano rispettano
abbastanza con precisione. Anche qua
abbiamo 90 miliardi e qui abbiamo
un'altra 3 mesi eh 90 miliardi. Questo
soltanto eh quando è stata 10 giorni la
scorsa settimana, quindi quello corto
termine è molto più frequente, mentre
invece ehm guardate già solo quella a 2
anni e delle notes abbiamo un 30 31
miliardi offerti.
Ovviamente c'è tanta c'è stata dom tanta
domanda per i 2 anni, particolarmente
alta, tra l'altro. Ehm
ma sennò ad esempio vedete già il 20
anni qua 13 miliardi,
il 5 anni qua no, è una strip, una
strip.
Ecco qua, 5 anni abbiamo 27 miliardi,
quindi una proporzione molto molto
diversa. Se noi incorporiamo
tutte le scadenze che sono quelle eh
3 mesi, un mese, eh 2 mesi, 6 mesi, la
gran parte si concentra, si vede
direttamente da qua un mese, 2 mesi, 3
mesi, 6 mesi. Quindi di tutte le TBills
che sono uscite che non pagano il
rendimento, ma hanno uno sconto, cioè
quindi scontano.
Abbiamo un totale di 95 90, vabbè,
abbiamo un quasi un 400 miliardi nel
giro di eh una settimana in TBills,
mentre invece 2 anni ne passa tra uno e
l'altro, insomma.
Ehm
se andiamo ancora più indietro, vediamo.
90 giorni.
Vorrei beccare una a 10 anni. Quando
siamo a 10 anni, non ricordo che più
metà ottobre.
Metà ottobre. Sì, l'8 ottobre,
figuratevi una volta al mese c'è quella
10 anni c'è stata sono stati offerti
solo 39 miliardi solo, insomma, in
confronto a a tutto il resto. Se
guardate quelle tedesche, i numeri
cambiano notevolmente
proprio per la natura del debito
americano e di quanto sia intrinseco, di
quanto sia estremamente desiderato, ma
come quantità offerte della tesoreria
direttamente siamo direttamente
decisamente su un'altra scala.
Si può vedere direttamente, dai. Ehm,
Germany.
Eh, andiamo a vedere tedeschi. Vabbè, le
aste da 13 anni c'hanno
cazzo l'ass da 13 anni. da 10 anni
stiamo parlando di 5 miliardi che
comunque contro i 40 del di USA
è sì decisamente un sesto.
Eh i bubil che tra l'altro i TBILS in
germanico si chiamano Bubil,
però comunque stiamo parlando di 2
miliardi, 3 miliardi sono decisamente
un'altra proporzione. Comunque
se lo togliamo,
ritorniamo a noi.
Eh, è un'assa elettronica che dura 2
minuti e abbiamo eh seguono un piano
seguono
un piano
più o meno definito. Viene definito
appunto nel Q& A. Poi possono esserci
delle modifiche minime tra un trimesse e
l'altro. Eh, quindi scriviamo qua QR.
Ehm,
poi abbiamo ehm
Allora, adesso entriamo nella parte,
diciamo, altre definizioni importanti
prima di quella che è eh andare a
definire proprio come funziona l'assa.
Allora, abbiamo detto che è un'assa
elettronica, ma chi ci partecipa?
abbiamo i ehm i più grandi
partecipanti alle aste sono i primary
dealers
e a loro io dedicherei poi vabbè, prima
andiamo a definire
eh tutte le tipologie di di
partecipanti, poi ci andremo a
concentrare più su una parte più
sull'altra.
Ehm,
scriviamo anche grandi investitori,
stiamo parlando di fondi, no? Quindi
grandi investitori
eh investitori
altre tipologie di istituzioni
finanziarie perché
come nella categoria dei dei primary
dealers
rientrano fondamentalmente le grandi mar
le grandi banche statunitensi. E poi
dopo vi faccio vedere dove si reperisce
la lista esatta perché c ogni tanto
cambiano, però le classiche sono una
decina, se non sbaglio, poco più di sono
grandissime banche
che fanno a gara tra di loro per
partecipare, per fare da da da primary
dealer e ogni tanto vengono aggiunte,
altre volte vengono tolte. Eh, poi vi
spiego qual è la funzione loro. Poi
abbiamo mh
piccoli medi investitori,
piccoli investitori, non intendo una
persona con ehm
€100.000 da investire.
Comunque stiamo parlando di piccoli
medi, ma stiamo parlando già nella scala
dei milioni in ogni caso, no?
Eh, perché se io piccolo investitore
voglio comprare del debito,
avrò bisogno di un intermediario per
partecipare questa asta elettronica,
insomma, è un po' è un po' complicata,
no?
Allora, eh abbiamo i
ehm
loro,
ovviamente qua rientriamo anche nei eh
ora in institutions, quindi le
istituzioni
ehm straniere, possono essere grandi
banche straniere che assolutamente
investono. ehm
nel nel debito stazionitense, come
abbiamo detto ad esempio prima delle nel
caso del Giappone,
qui abbiamo
e queste sono le competitive bits,
quindi che competono alla eh all'AST,
quindi abbiamo sempre la la Treasury, la
scrivo con T, che in questo caso fa
l'offerta No,
quello che fanno queste categorie qui è
mettere la domanda, no? Quindi
esattamente come su un DOM, su un
insomma normale uno scambio dove c'è
un'offerta, c'è una c'è un ask, c'è un
bid, c'è un'offerta e c'è una bid. Ehm,
vengono piazzate delle bid. Ehm,
nel caso del
competitive bits,
eh, l'offerente specifica
quantità
che desidera acquistare
e il rendimento che desidera.
Se le cose
non combaciano,
ad esempio, se il mercato sta tradando
il 4%, io voglio, sono un competitivo,
quindi ho la possibilità di fare questa
pretesa.
Se io voglio un rendimento del 4,04
posso includerlo nell'asta, però se ehm
l'offerente, quindi la Treasury, non lo
accetta,
la mia la mia bid decade, io non posso
essere fillato. Ovviamente poi ehm
qua è più che altro una cosa del genere
e non competitive qua sotto
che specificano solo la quantità, non
possono pretendere nessun tipologia di
rendimento, prendono il rendimento da a
cui finisce l'asta e basta. Ehm,
appunto, se il rendimento è troppo alto
rispetto eh a quello a cui si chiude
l'asta, eh l'offerta non viene accettata
semplicemente e e basta. Io rimango col
senza e basta. Ehm,
ora direi che ora possiamo concentrarci
su chi sono loro e perché sono
estremamentissimamente
importanti
i primary dealers. E questo merita uno
schema tutto. Oh, mi è andato, sono
andato fuori dalla tabella cosa.
Questo merita proprio una sezione a
parte.
Allora, cosa succede? Qual è il ciclo
del debito? Abbiamo il mercato primario.
Il mercato primario è proprio l'asta
stessa, perché io prima quando ho detto
di che cosa parlavamo ehm da dove si
origina e doveva a finire
immediatamente, abbiamo il mercato
primario che è la l'asta stessa
e abbiamo i primary dealer. I primary
dealers servono a fornire liquidità alla
tesoreria stessa. Loro fondamentalmente
fanno da market maker
al dipartimento della tesoneria,
quindi fanno in modo così come un market
maker facilita ehm il trading su
qualsiasi mercato, così loro lo
facilitano durante l'asta, che è un
mercato eh a s stante, quel quei 2
minuti in cui abbiamo l'asta, loro
devono fornire liquidità, devono fare in
modo che la tesoreria riesca ad ottenere
ehm
riesca ad ottenere il denaro che le
serve. Se c'è poca ehm
eh poca domanda dai altre tipologie di
partecipanti, vuol dire che i primary
dealers dovranno
richiedere più, cioè coprire di più la
l'offerta disponibile per fare in modo
che l'assa si concluda e insomma che che
che laeria ottenga il denaro. Quindi
fanno un po' da quelli che tengono sul
castello di carta,
eh, per così dire,
ehm, nel momento eh stesso
che ehm
che loro insomma si ritrovano con la la
patata bollente in mano e vanno a eh e
si trovano con questo debito e non
sanno, tra virgolette, che cosa farsene.
diventano prendono la parte eh qui
prendono la buy side, no? per buy side
fanno il marker market maker però
specialmente nella dalla parte buy
perché piazzano delle bidano da ehm
fanno da liquidità alla alla tesoreria,
ma poi abbiamo i mercati secondari
che tramite i primary dealers loro
stessi,
stiamo sempre parlando di primary
dealers loro stessi
rimettono eh
fanno da sell side e rendono questo
debito se lo tengono per sé. Ovviamente
poi ci sono dei meccanismi interni
particolari che a noi interessano
relativamente, ci interessa solo la loro
capacità massima di assorbire ehm il
debito, le le le l'offerta di debito eh
della tesoreria. Poi per il resto di
come viene poi riemesso e in quale
misura il il debito nei mercati
secondari non è così deterministico,
insomma, nella nostra analisi, ma
comunque fanno da cellel side in modo
che chiunque non sia riuscito a
partecipare all'asta primaria o chiunque
non ne abbia assolutamente la la
possibilità va da loro e quindi io ehm
io anche investitore
privato, vado e acquisto da questa
grande banca, da Primary Dealers del
obbligazioni statunitensi di qualsiasi
naturalesse siano. Ovviamente, che cosa
fa il primary dealers? si fa compensare
per fare questa cosa eh comeè giusto che
sia il suo compenso
e ehm
se loro l'hanno hanno bloccato un
rendimento X, quello che passeranno a me
come come acquirente avrà del markup a
me come a un qualsiasi altro ehm
partecipante, insomma.
Ehm
Sì, sì, diciamo di sì.
E è tutto
secondari.
È chiaro questa cosa dei primary
dealers?
Scusa, è laggato un attimo.
>> No, dico, è abbastanza chiaro questa
cosa dei primary dealers che ci
rivertono e diventano immediatamente
sellati
by side. Mh
>> mh. Sì, a me sì.
>> Ottimo, ottimo.
E fondamentalmente il mercato secondario
è
ehm è mercato libero, no? l'open market
nei
nell'open market eh
l'open market è molto molto vasto, nel
senso nel l'open market dei mercati
secondari, quindi vabbè, adesso tolto il
baccio qua,
però abbiamo ehm nei mercati secondari
chiunque non sia che che ne abbia
bisogno e così via, abbiamo Abbiamo
di nuovo abbiamo investitori
istituzionali come fondi pensione,
tutti coloro che non sono, diciamo,
autorizzati o che non sono riusciti a
partecipare all'asta principale, no?
Quindi abbiamo i fondi pensione,
eh assicurazione,
ehm fondi comuni
di qualsiasi nature adesso siano,
quindi anche gente che mette soldi
insieme, insomma gente tra virgolette.
Poi abbiamo le banche centrali estere
che vanno sempre nei mercati secondari
tramite intermediario o direttamente con
la loro moneta, perché ovviamente
avranno bisogno se non passano tra
tramite un intermediario devono
scambiare le loro riserve di moneta in
cambio di dollari, no? Quindi per
acquistare ehm
eh tesoreria americana ci vuole comunque
del dollaro perché viene messa
esclusivamente in dollari e per andare
sul mercato USA ad acquistare del delle
obbligazioni USA abbiamo bisogno del
dollaro, così come abbiamo bisogno di
euro per acquistare il debito italiano.
Ehm
e poi abbiamo ovviamente la Federal
Reserve, quello che
è super importante in questi giorni, che
finalmente
diventa di nuovo un partecipante della
dell'open delle operazioni di mercato
aperto o omo
omo.
Ehm,
quindi m
che adesso hanno annunciato, abbiamo
visto con il lo qualcuno ha pubblicato e
continueranno
cominceranno con l'acquisto di Trejury
Bills per, diciamo, per normalizzare un
po' la situazione di liquidità, eh per
assorbire un po' di
insomma di di migliorare
la situazione con l'acquisto di T Bills,
ne parla anche McElligot un pochino,
anzi anche il video di Federico che ha
fatto è molto molto belle nella parte
iniziale specialmente,
almeno per quello che piace a me, ehm
durante quantitativas fondamentalmente
la Federal Reserve eh potrebbe aver
bisogno di stimolare le l'economia,
quindi acquisterà massicciamente ente
treasury e altri titoli sul mercato
secondari.
Ovviamente Treasury principalmente
perché sono gli asset più sicuri. Gli
asset ad esempio le equities sono sempre
poco sicuri in proporzione a quanto a
quanto Treasury
TBS in particolare viene scambiato. Sono
sono il nulla, no? Ehm
eh facendo questo, acquistando i titoli
di stato, eh ne abbasserei, essendo che
ne acquista massicciamente, parliamo
davvero di massicciamente tanto tanto,
ne abbasserà il rendimento facendone
aumentare il prezzo. Durante il
quantitative tightening, invece li
vendono così, eh abbassano il prezzo e
aumentano il rendimento. Quindi questo è
un altro eh strumento di controllo che
la Federal Reserva ha, quindi è un un
circolo, no?
Ehm,
dunque, vediamo se mi sono balzato
qualcosa.
Altri esempi di
partecipanti.
Ok, allora abbiamo
eh
momento. Scusate che sto riguardando un
attimo la nota
che sono sicuro di aver dimenticato
qualcosa e che sia tutto in ordine,
no? Va bene, va bene così.
Beh, questa cosa della Federal Reserve è
abbastanza semplice. Eh,
quali sono adesso i
parametri di una eh auction? Vabbè, a
parte che abbiamo ad esempio i
abbiamo prendiamo ad esempio i 90
miliardi
di TBLS, no? Questa è la quantità
che viene offerta, quindi abbiamo 90
miliardi.
Si tiene l'asta
e il primo dato importante è il eh il
bid to cover. Il bid to cover è derivato
da quanta domanda,
quindi quantità di domanda
rispetto a questi 90 miliardi. Quindi se
ehm l'asta offerta è di 90 miliardi, ma
facciamo un esempio tondo, arrivano eh
bits per una quantità totale di 270
miliardi e quindi è tre volte l'offerta,
avremo un bit cover di 3.0,
no?
Ehm, a noi arriva soltanto questo dato
qua, diciamo, su refinitive e
quant'altro. Abbiamo solo questo dato
qua che ci interessa come dato diretto.
Ehm,
poi abbiamo il secondo dato importante è
l'Idray,
che quindi è il rendimento massimo a cui
si è conclusa l'asta. Quindi il
rendimento massimo a cui si conclude
l'assa è quello che ehm
tutti quanti ricevono, compresi anche i
non competitivi.
Quindi il vabbè y la yield è il massimo
che perché ricordate quando vi dicevo
prima del eh che i competitive hanno la
possibilità e la facoltà di specificare
il rendimento che desiderano. Loro
determinano che
ehm
per acquistare il debito a 30 anni
americano, in un periodo di incertezza,
vogliono essere ricompensati
maggiormente e ottenere un rendimento
maggiore rispetto a quello che è il
nominale che sta tradanno in determinato
momento, loro specificheranno che
vogliono un extra, no, un del premio
rispetto a quello che è il
il rendimento che c'è in quel
determinato momento,
se sono tutti più o meno d'accordo e per
facilitare la fine dell'asta
la Treasury è costretta ad ad accettare
la yield sarà eh superiore al tempo di
eh al
Sate cominciando a fare gli svarioni
dopo 2 ore quasi. ehm sarà costretto ad
accettare un rendimento maggiore,
pertanto, perché ovviamente vogliono i
soldi e quindi in un qualche modo devono
accontentare tutti quanti
e concederanno questo rendimento
maggiore. Diciamo che nel caso delle
Tbills non ce n'è bisogno, abbiamo visto
prima, non c'è bisogno di farle finire
in coso in
ad un rendimento più di tanto maggiore
perché abbiamo dei bit to cover
quest'anno
molto elevati. Abbiamo un B to cover
2.92, ad esempio, per i 6 mesi. 2.62
è un po' più basso, però solitamente
sopra il due che quindi arrivano bits,
il doppio rispetto in quantità doppia
rispetto a quella che è l'offerta,
allora va bene, vedete qua abbiamo i 2
mesi a 2.88 dire che c'è tanta domanda
per debito a corto termine. Qui abbiamo
sull'anno addirittura un 3.21, 21 vuol
dire che hanno offerto oltre tre volte i
52 miliardi, quindi più di 150 miliardi
sono arrivati eh in BX, no? Eh, qui
abbiamo 600 miliardi un 2.87 molto
elevato. Qua c'abbiamo debit to cover
invece per il debito tedesco a 1.20, ma
io le asse del debito tedesco non l'ho
mai capito perché finiscono tutte con un
bit cover così basso che sono giusto
giusto
ehm sufficienti a eh a coprire.
Eh l'average yield. Qua c'avete il
rendimento medio a cui eh viene conclusa
l'assa, però in realtà Ah, ecco,
ecco, ecco, abbiamo yieldil, la yield,
eh low yield,
ma mettiamo anche questo
che vabbè questo sarà e abbiamo un
dato un po' più Vediamo se li calcola
perché mi sa che una volta già li avevo
Ehm,
vedete qua, ecco, c'abbiamo, lo mettiamo
di fianco al bit to cover così
e però non posso vero
uno di fianco all'altro.
Ok,
vedete che corrisponde 2.92 * 80.63 63
farà sicuramente 228 miliardi o comunque
uno diviso l'altro, no?
Ehm, aspettate che guardo se c'è un
altro dato. Sai dovuto avrei dovuto eh
prepararmene ste cose, ma proprio per la
naturalezza.
No,
ancora questo non credo che lo capino.
Poi abbiamo l'IELD, appunto, che è del
3.7,
che è quello che dicevamo, un 3.7. Ehm,
è quello che poi si conclude l'asta e
tutti quanti felici e contenti ottengono
questo rendimento su questo questa TBS e
questa AST.
E c'era un periodo e ancora adesso è
abbastanza così,
no? Qua abbiamo un 20 anni di 2.73, ma
l'anno scorso
verso settembre-ottobre c'erano le AS da
di 30 anni e 20 anni che continuavano a
finire con bit to cover veramente
pessimi. Erano eravamo sui 2.20, ma in
continuazione.
Ehm,
quindi una domanda molto bassa, tanta
incertezza sul futuro, ma ci stava, era
il periodo anche su Trump e quant'altro,
quindi incorpora tanto la l'incertezza
questo dato.
quando
la yield eh
quando c'è la
può finire
si dice che quando la yield è superiore
al eh rendimento
issued.
Quindi,
nel momento in cui termina l'asta e
riprende tutto quanto normalmente,
se ehm la yield è superiore si si chiama
si dice che si che la l'asta finisce in
tail.
La differenza tra
il l' rate ehm
era è positiva, insomma finisce in tail.
Quando invece è negativa si dice stop
true,
quando c'è talmente tanta eh offrono de
dei rendimenti desiderati bassi, quindi
riescono per per essere certi certissimi
di riuscire a ad aggiudicarsi
quest'asta,
ehm l'asta finisce con un rendimento
minore rispetto a Voglio farvi vedere un
esempio concreto sulla chart proprio,
però devo fare se avete pazienza,
vedete qua, dovrebbe
calcolare la tail perché lo stop through
non so se mai finisca in stop, io non
l'ho mai visto finire in stop, quindi
tanto, cioè molto molto raro, non dico
proprio mai mai
ehm
Allora, voglio farvi vedere proprio
l'esempio sul
però devo andarmi a prendere
un asta perché lo si vede lo si vede
proprio sulla chat, ma vi faccio un
disegnino cò prima.
Quando un'asta finisce in ehm
diciamo che il mercato sta tradore.
Abbiamo la linea del prezzo, no? Il
mercato prima dell'asta sta tradando
solitamente in un range, no? Quindi
immaginiamoci che alle 19
abbiamo un rendimento per questo titolo
di qualsiasi tipo che sia, abbiamo un
rendimento del 4%, no? Immaginiamoci qua
che che ci sia il 4%, qua abbiamo il 3
98 perché mi piace e e abbiamo questo
range qui, no? Poi scattano le 19:02.
L'asta
finisce,
ma si materializza sulla chart una
spike.
Questo se abbiamo un data feed che non
cattura esattamente il momento dell'asta
con grandissima precisione, quindi che
prende qualsiasi eh movimento ci possa
essere e diciamo che questa spike va a
finire.
rapidamente molto più in alto rispetto
al range, però finisce l'asta 1902 e
ritorna al 4% che stava tradando. Inizia
Madonna, quanto l'ho rovinato sto al 4%
iniziale che stava tradando prima.
Questo era particolarmente visibile coi
dati trade web in cui vedevi queste
spike gigantesche e poi il mercato
tornava.
Ehm,
quindi per dire che questa la tail si
vedeva e c'è proprio questo nome perché
fa questa svirgolata
e e poi vabbè, fa questa svirgolata e
poi ritorna a tradare normalmente.
A volte, visto che questo è molto
significativo,
può capitare che il mercato subito dopo,
immediatamente
possa ritornarci, no? Anche per le
movimentazioni che succedono
immediatamente nei mercati secondari,
quello che vogliamo, no? ehm e così via
e poi fare tutto quello che vogliamo.
Ora questi livelli in ogni caso
ci sta a monitorare il rendimento del
titolo,
ad esempio, a 10 anni, perché il nostro
pr, il nostro benchmark, il nostro
Grande Fratello,
se noi andiamo a prendere, ad esempio,
vediamo cosa fa, facciamo un grande
esempio qui adesso, prendere i livelli
che derivano dall'asta.
Eh sì, vediamo. Siamo gli ultimi 30
giorni,
però non so se prendo
l'ultima del 10 anni.
Eh, è utile monitorare il livello di
rendimento
finale dell'ultima asta, anche per i
giorni venire, magari segnarseli sul ehm
sul grafico, quello dei rendimenti
ovviamente, oppure se riuscite a
mappare, se c'avete voglia di mapparvi
ehm
qual era in corrispondenza, ad esempio,
il prezzo del
del
del Tanger. Questa è l'ultima. Sì,
avevamo una yield del 4.11,70, 11,70.
Quindi se ora andiamo 4 11 170
andiamo qua sul grafico,
facciamo un bel copia incolla.
Il caso vuole che
il caso vuole che siamo esattamente qui,
no? Però, insomma, dall'8 di ottobre
questo è stato
8 ottobre, si presuma, alle 19.
Questo è stato il rendimento
in questo giorno
e poi beh, ha fatto da supporto nella
giornata successiva, quindi da
resistenza su Zen, quindi a validità nel
corto
perché ehm
insomma chi ha acquistato
la tesoreria che si è bloccato quello
magari ha bisogno di un po' di tempo per
adeguarsi, insomma, per cominciare a
mediare il suo rischio di di tasso e di
quel che si vuole e quindi magari
quest'area potrebbe essere difesa un po'
di più nel corto termine. Adesso siamo
qui, però ovviamente mh
come vabbè, il caso vuole che siamo
proprio tre volte che andiamo a
rimbalzare su questo livello, però non
direi che abbia una validità, diciamo,
da dire a questo livello vale anche tre
settimane dopo. Quello no, da dire così,
no. Poi tanto lì può rimanere, no?
quello dell'ultima asse, poi si sposta
in modo itinerante. Avanti e avanti.
Ehm,
scriviamolo qui così lo monitoriamo
anche
la prossima volta ci ricordiamo questo
grafico qua. Me lo tengo sempre lì e poi
man mano che facciamo le lezioni che
vediamo di spostarlo avanti tutti
insieme. Ehm,
basta. Sì, ci sta. Però vedete e vale
vale solo vale particolarmente nel
giorno dopo. Adesso che siamo qui adesso
è più caso che altro.
Eh, poi
cosa c'è ancora da coprire sul verde
sulle?
Ovviamente
mvito.
le notes, ad esempio, no, quelle che
quindi hanno una durata più lunga, ma di
qualsiasi durata,
oltre ai mercati secondari può anche
finire m primo ordine dei derivati eh
non leverage, che quindi sono gli swaps,
quindi m
fondamentalmente il debito viene
scambiato AT tra tasso fisso e tasso
variabile
in una maniera infinita di modi
e di combinazioni diverse di formule
l'uno per l'altro e insomma giusto per
non
per non tenerlo fisso lì in base alla
necessità che il chi è detentore di uno
di o dell'altra tipologia di che bisogno
ne abbia. G swaps li vediamo nella
prossima lezione di come si collegano,
insomma, sono sempre derivati, per noi
sono importanti, ma ahimè, essendo che
sono proprio over the counter, la
quantità di dati che abbiamo a
disposizione per fare una decisione,
insomma, un po' più con un peso un po'
maggiore, è limitata, però andremo a
vedere gli swaps sul sui software e gli
overnight index swap.
Ehm, mi un pochettino anche, ma ce
l'avete tra l'altro anche sulla
quadboard. Ehm, andiamo a vedere i
forwards e queste cose, ma questo è
l'argomento per la prossima edizione.
Ok,
vi metto un po' una nota, ma è da
importante ehm
per noi trader di Treasury è importante
avere a mente che cos'è il cheapest to
deliver. Ehm,
praticamente
i future sulla sulle treasury ZN, come
abbiamo visto prima, hanno un range, no?
Quindi non sono legate a una ehm
scadenza fissa, un titolo fisso, anche
perché nel momento stesso in cui ehm
viene emesso un titolo, il suo ciclo di
vita inizia e ha un termine ben
stabilito, no?
Quindi hanno eh scadenze residue
diverse. Il Chippers to Deliver è il
titolo all'interno di questo
gruppo, di questo range, di questo
paniere che ha il costo minore per
essere consegnato fisicamente alla
scadenza del future.
Quindi se uno ehm vuole far scadere il
future detenendolo senza arrollarlo all
scadenza successiva, c'è la delivery.
In pratica loro il
il CPS deliver rappresenta il prezzo
meno caro tra tutto questo paniere alla
scadenza, diciamo. La formula non è
semplice, ma ehm ve la mando, ve la
guardate. Io sto esaurendo le parole a
riguardo.
Eh, una grandissima, bisogna tenere nota
presente del fatto che anche una
grandissima fetta di volumi che abbiamo
sui mercati
Treasury Futures
e in generale sono eh gli algoritmi che
tradano il basis che quindi vanno a
exploitare la differenza momentanea tra
il sottostante e il future.
Quindi azzerando, tra virgolette
gran parte di questo vantaggio. questo
vantaggio non siamo abbastanza veloci da
sfruttarlo per il discorso del della
coda, della rapidità di esecuzione, del
fatto che il basis e la differenza tra
sottostante e il future e a volte è
talmente stretta, insomma, quando capita
che l'inefficienza si crea, comunque per
noi entrare, ad esempio, con un market
non è non è vantaggioso perché potrebbe
essere troppo stretta la differenza per
trarre realmente vantaggio tra eh dal
basis. Per quello bisognerebbe avere un
algoritmo che sta lì e cerca di
catturare la coda minore possibile e si
adegua in base aspettando solo il
momento in cui il basis trade si
materializzi, ma insomma stiamo stiamo
parlando di competere, insomma, di fare
un layering sull'intero book e di
rimuovere eh gli ordini alla velocità
della luce in base a al movimento. ai ai
volumi effettivi, a meno che non si
presenti questa inefficienza. Insomma,
se abbiamo un algoritmo che fa solo
quello, diciamo che non possiamo non
possiamo competere.
Va bene? Eh, la parte teorica è
abbastanza coperta.
Ehm,
allora sappiate che in all'atto pratico
quello che ci interessa particolarmente
sono le le option dei 5, dei 2, dei 10,
dei 20 e dei 30 perché andranno saranno
quelli che andranno a portare la
maggiore ehm volatilità sul nostro
sui mercati che stiamo tradando, quelli
usuali, quelli su T Bills, poca roba,
più che altro perché
non c'è grandissimo shock su quei
mercati, insomma,
non non uscirà mai un bit to cover che è
particolarmente sballato rispetto alla
norma, no? Quindi sono abbastanza
tranquilli, non portano volatilità
particolare, ci sono e basta. quello eh
si va a vedere magari quello per
un'altra tipologia di trading.
Per noi invece se esce un
se unta finisce in tail sui 30 anni,
allora è Berish per ZB e UB sui 20 e sui
30 anni sulle asse di debito dei titoli
a 20 e 30 anni. Eh, e berish nel corto
termine
non sempre si materializza, come dicevo
prima, eh immediatamente, ma potrebbe
materializzarsi nella sessione seguente
oppure se c'è un trend su diversi mesi
di poca domanda sul sul debito a lungo
termine, allora lo va a rafforzare come
abbiamo adesso, no? eh quello che che è
il problema attuale della dei mercati
problema
che nessuno si pone a quanto pare, ma
comunque c'è tanto desiderio per debito
a corto termine rispetto a quello a
lungo termine proprio per la situazione
di incertezza, ma quello ne avevo
parlato abbondantemente.
Va bene, domande? E poi io passerei a
fare un po' di pratica di giornata
finale.
Nessuna domanda?
Io non ho domande,
ho preso appunti, ma sono a posto.
>> Nemmeno io.
>> Benissimo, Emy, niente domande,
approfondimenti.
>> Già similare a tutto quello che ha detto
mi ci vorrà.
>> Eh, mi si è allontanata. qui solo per
fare la brava studentessa, invece sta
guardando il telefono.
[risate]
Tiro il gessetto.
>> Guarda che io son qua. Sono
No, niente. Io pure ho preso un po' di
appunti sul telefono, poi al massimo mi
rivedo il video se c'ho altri
approfondimenti come l'altra volta che
stavo
Sì, probabilmente anch'io riguardando
magari perché poi tanto se riguardo
tutte le lezioni
mi verrà qualche domanda da farti, ma
nel caso la scrivo, però adesso come
adesso cosa?
Sì, io idem di base tutta la parte
dell'asta già la sapevo, però me lo
riguarderò con interesse.
>> Grazie che mi compiace.
Allora,
eh
va bene. Allora, io mi prenderei solo un
briciolo di pausa perché se esaito il
fiato e la saliva.
Poi facciamo fino alle un pochino di
pausa, fino alle 7:30 e poi possiamo
fare un po' di pratica, un po' di un po'
di analisi,
un po' di di queste cose qua un po' più
un po' più rilassanti.
Poi non che questo noi di cui abbiamo
parlato fino adesso non si è resistanza
pronto.
Passiamo a al momento attuale. Ok. Alle
7:30 torno.
Ok,
sei tornato. Allora, vi volevo far
vedere ancora
qu che vi dicevo prima dei primary
dealers che mi è venuto in mente. Nel
frattempo
non ricordo su che sia fred
m ovviamente.
Eccoli qua.
corrente. Abbiamo un sacco di di
banche. Abbiamo anche la banca di
Montreal, però con sede a Chicago.
Anche una banca canadese. VNP Paribà
Barkley Bofa, Bank of America,
Centur, Fitzgerald, City Group, eh
Deutch Bank, Goldman CSB, HSBC,
Jeffer, AJP Morgan, insomma tutti
quelli.
Security Steve US, quindi eh giapponese,
Nomura, anche lì giapponese,
eh Santander,
Sozietà General,
quindi tutte abbiamo anche tutte le ehm
le banche grandi banche a estere che
hanno comunque un delle filiali che sono
presenti sullo stato americano e
i requisiti per essere una di per
rientrare qui tra i grandi squali
sono molto stringenti,
eh anche perché loro devono assicurarsi
di avere abbastanza denaro, devono
essere banche gigantesche.
Ehm,
poi abbiamo un'altra cosa, eh,
ecco, ehm,
abbiamo anche una
ehm
alcune metriche che mi sono dimenticato
di coprire che sono
ehm Ehm,
abbiamo
una precisione
abbiamo ne abbiamo coperta una di due di
importanti che sono eh il B2 cover e la
Yield, ma abbiamo anche ehm
i indirect bits,
che quindi possono essere indiretti, nel
senso che usano intermediario,
solitamente sono banche o istituzioni
estere, una percentuale elevata di
indirex,
ehm,
ad esempio, sulle scadenze più lunghe
solitamente
Vuol dire che c'èzioni
estere
e è una percentuale e se è
particolarmente elevata, specialmente
ehm sulla parti lunghe e della della
curva, su scadenze lunghe, significa che
c'è parecchia fiducia nei
negli Stati Uniti in questo caso.
Abbiamo invece
i direct
che sono quelli domestici normali.
Poi abbiamo appunto eh stop through e
yield abbiamo coperti. Questi sono gli
internals della
auction.
I direct, i domestici ovviamente sono
rientrano in questa categoria anche i
primary dealers, quindi la percentuale
sarà meno volatile, sarà sempre elevata,
no? insomma, ehm,
poi anche nella
dei primary dealers, nello specifico
dealers
take down,
quindi è la percentuale
che i primary dealers sono stati
costretti
eh ad assorbire
ad assorbire per far finire l'asta.
Quindi abbiamo detto prima che loro sono
obbligati a eh investire ingenti somme
nelle nelle asse del tesoro perché sono
ehm sono quelli che tengono sullo schema
ponzi dellester dell'estremo eterno
debito.
Ehm,
questo è che ad assorbire
ehm
ehm una quindi una percentuale alta,
diciamo,
se già è superiore a un 15-20%
per le scadenze lunghe è un segnale
abbastanza ribassissa, perché vuol dire
che davvero l'outlook per ehm
per
il futuro è è molto
è pessimo, insomma.
Quindi il mercato non ha assorbito
l'offerta
e sono stati loro costretti a ad
assorbirla. c'è un limite totale,
insomma, stimato che
c'è una misura anche proprio di di
quanto i primer dealers sono la la
capacity totale di quanto possono
assorbire, perché
ehm
è una definizione, è una metrica, è una
caratteristica che esiste, ma non è già
è già capitato che venisse semplicemente
Ehm, in caso di necessità mi pare che
fosse
capitato che il massimo che i primer
dealers possono detenere
e in termini di di titoli, ehm,
insomma, aspettate. Allora,
c'è un tetto massimo che i primary
dealers. Allora, è vero che i primer
sono obbligati ad assorbire l'offerta,
ma c'è anche un teorico limite.
C'è stato un periodo pochi mesi fa in
cui erano a vicini a questo tetto. C'è
anche da dire però che è un numero e che
quindi può essere semplicemente
modificato a piacimento al momento che
che ce ne sia bisogno, anche perché le
aste devono essere devono continuare ad
essere facilitate proprio per tutto il
discorso che eh di rifinanziamento del
debito del del rollover, quindi e e di
pagamento di quello che che c'è da
pagare, no? Quindi i primer dealers
devono continuare la loro funzione a
prescindere. sono tutti quei tasselli
del di tutto di tutto lo schemino, di
tutto di tutto quanto il funzionamento
che devono funzionare, la Fed che
interviene da un lato, i primer dealers
che intervengono dall'altro, insomma
deve essere tutto atto a a continuare a
finanziare le operazioni di governo e
far sembrare, insomma, che sia che sia
tutto nella norma, tutto a posto. sono
dei limiti che sono stati messi, perché
poi ovviamente lo sappiamo e ehm per
dare un senso di legittimità a tutto
quanto, no? E quindi devono essere lì,
devono essere dichiarati, ma
esattamente come il tetto del debito,
sono cose che possono essere modificate
a necessità, insomma.
Va bene, c'erano solo per queste ultime
due cose qua. Ecco qui il mio bellissimo
schemino. Madonna, quanta roba oggi.
Bene, allora dai, direi che va bene
così.
Per la parte teorica
avevo rimesso l'audio su OBS. Sì, fammi
controllare se su YouTube è tutto a
posto.
>> Qui questo ce lo condividi questo
documento così com'è.
Certo,
anche quelli delle altre volte se
volete.
>> Anzi, fammi gi male.
>> Certo.
Avevi una domanda. Hai detto
no. Eh no, ho detto non sarebbe male se
lo condividi. Non non una domanda. Ah,
certo, certo.
Facciamo proprio così,
>> così riusciamo a piratare bene tutto a
quelli che ci pagano per avere lei.
M intanto lo metto qua, così non me lo
perdo e poi lo metto nel posto giusto,
nella specifico nella della lezione,
eh, quando poi la pubblico sul canale.
Allora,
in realtà ci sono tutti quelli
dell'altra volta.
Cioè, vabbè, c'era quella di Xinit, ma è
molto tecnico. Qua era
avevo fatto un disegno che non c'entra
niente, che era più per la parte
operativa in realtà. Nella lezione di
Exenit c'è questo screenshot, ma eh poi
in realtà era stata più la parte
operativa, quella interessante.
Va bene. Allora,
questo è che c'erano due volte. Vabbè,
allora
ormai siamo belli che riallineati con il
con gli USA come tempi, quindi va bene.
Quello che mi che mi piace di meno è il
cambio dell'ora primaverile. A me eh mi
dà proprio fastidio perché è più lungo,
loro cambiano prima di noi,
quindi dura più a lungo.
Vabbè, dopo l'asta non è che sia
successo più di tanto oggi.
Z fa cos'è che mi ha inventato qua?
Io ho acceso
bookmaps abbastanza tardi,
però cosa abbiamo qua? Poi abbiamo
questa.
Allora,
qui era interessante, era quello che
parlavamo anche con Manuele, questa
liquidità che c'è stata per tutta la
l'inizio della sessione fino a poi
arrivare al al PMI. Qui includiamo anche
l'apertura equities.
Ehm,
range infinitissimo.
Non ho la parte di di apertura precisa,
ma eh eh
andiamo a prenderci la chart per vedere
che cosa è capitato da quel momento.
Abbiamo avuto
prima, già in premarket, abbiamo avuto
una svendita che non non ho idea del
perché.
Ho aperto il mercato cash bel range e
poi
da qui possiamo continuare anche da qui,
eh. Madonna, però
il muretto di liquidità. Intanto chi chi
ha già provato a mettere le mani,
insomma, sul sulla parte pratica di
usare la trader map, così avrà già
notato l'utilità. Allora, come come
interpretare questo?
Ehm, qui abbiamo
un sacco di di di lotti,
eh
tanta liquidità al al bottom del range,
meno al top ne avevamo,
dava una certa direzionalità, ma al top
ce l'avevamo su altre parti della della
curva, sulle due è comparsa diverse
volte,
ma in ogni caso era abbastanza aperto
sia da da un lato del che dall'altro.
qua sopra aveva fatto del volume,
abbastanza volume prima di di svendere.
Però quando quando abbiamo queste
tipologie di range, quello che che
succede è che abbiamo un fulcro, il
mercato si allontana prima da una parte,
prima dall'altra, abbiamo un
esaurimento, ehm, copertura che sia da
un lato che sia dall'altro, abbiamo
copertura e si ritorna verso il fulcro,
verso il PC. Quindi abbiamo il P qui in
esattamente al centro.
Quando abbiamo queste questi muretti per
dargli più validità
possiamo proprio vedere il il volume
scambiato qui sotto. Quindi va in bid,
c'è la sondina tra virgolette,
quindi viene scambiato questo
minima quantità di ordine o nessuna.
Se la bidge,
allora rafforza l'idea di eh che questo
sia un un
che può essere utilizzato come segnale
forte di domanda, no? Quindi di
pressione buy.
Ovviamente entrare qua sotto è
completamente impossibile, totalmente
impossibile. Av 39 lotti e
non non può capitare. Difficile entrare
anche dopo, subito dopo, praticamente
nullo. Qui abbiamo avuto pulling. Questo
movimento qua è stato super rapido in
realtà, no? Ehm, nel giro di neanche un
minuto, magari uno c'ha la conferma qua,
ma neanche entrare a mercato, diciamo,
per prendere questo prezzo qua era
praticamente
quanto tempo c' c'è stato? Ok, questo è
stato in bid. Abbiamo avuto
una quarantina di secondo, quindi quando
questo era in B da entrare al mercato e
comprare per avere questo prezzo come
entrata era l'unica opzione. si può
fare. A volte mi è capitato di farlo, è
estremamente rischioso,
però tante volte vale anche il rischio
se il rischio è molto stretto, cioè
addirittura se tu hai uno stop volume e
se usate si gxo o cose del genere avete
i volume stop che dovete usare
assolutamente sulla Treasury perché,
come dicevo l'altra volta con uno stop
volume puoi avere uno stop molto più
stretto che viene triggerato in base
alla litiquidità. dovete scegliere su
Gigo è già in default su eh su
liquidità. Quindi, se tu mettevi ehm uno
stop per dire ehm che triggera solo
quando la liquidità raggiunge i 500 sul
livello, ehm
allora sei salvo anche se magari va in
bidia
niente oppure se scambia poco,
a meno che appunto non non viene rimossa
o non viene tradato un tanto volume, il
lo stop non triggera. Quindi qua
addirittura se uno faceva questa cosa
qua del comprare poteva mettere
direttamente lo stop qui. Cioè proprio
sto parlando di estrema precisione e di
riconoscimento dei pattern con un
determinata quantità di esperienza. C'è
da dire che
potrebbe sembrare la stessa cosa qui,
cioè non vuol dire che tutte le volte
che noi abbiamo contro un muretto un
esaurimento, quindi andiamo un bid e e
ritorniamo subito indietro, allora sia
valido. No, quello no. Ehm,
qua uno lo prendeva a quasi a solo per
la liquidità, ma quello che è
importante, diciamo, per costruire una
posizione importante, eh nel senso
valida dal punto di vista eh eh proprio
com'è che si dice,
non solo di io penso che no, per dire,
mi mancano le parole ormai Questo è la
lunga giornata. Sto sveglio dalle 4:00
di notte che sono sveglio, 4:00 di
mattina. Ehm,
prendere una posizione perché si
riconosce un pattern e decidere di
prendere il rischio va bene, ma per
dargli davvero validità, vedete che qui,
al contrario delle altre due volte
abbiamo anche uno riemozione, quindi
abbiamo il pulling che adesso sto usando
bookmapia
senza dover fare un replay, però il
bello di bookmap è proprio anche questo
che vi fa vedere il dettaglio, no? Qui
abbiamo la rimozione di liquidità
e un volume particolarmente elevato
rispetto a i buyers che ci sono stati
che non ci sono stati praticamente
vengono completamente surcassati da
questo. Quindi come dimensione abbiamo
questi 1656 lotti che hanno venduto,
che hanno immediatamente comprato.
Probabilmente non è nemmeno un caso.
potrebbe essere che,
cioè io penso sempre, queste sono
supposizioni,
ehm,
che possano essere gli stessi seller ad
aver coperto la loro posizione
super rapidamente. Ovviamente si tratta
di algoritmi, non non con con la più
grande possibilità, no? Quindi qui sono
andati in bidono riusciti ad arrivare
soltanto fin qui. Non c'è stato
continuo, se non questi 10 lottini qui.
Non c'è stato continuo. Aspettano che
arrivi del flow continuo ad uscire dal
range. c'è stato c'è liquid tanta
liquidità a bloccare, eh non c'è nessuno
che vuole prendere il passo o comunque
questo Bayer è abbastanza forte da da
dell'essere riuscito a prendere tutto
questo e non
e e averne ancora, no?
E quindi in ogni caso abbiamo uno swiip
a rialzo, quindi abbiamo sia una
rimozione liquidità -32 lotti più 1719
comprati con un flow continuo su
immediatamente dopo abbiamo un 100,
abbiamo un 5, abbiamo di nuovo riemzione
di liquidità e 2500 lotti scambiati.
Questo è già un momento abbastanza
sicuro per poter ci posizionare con un
buy
vicino al all'estremo
inferiore di un di un range di questo
tipo. Quindi con una bella bid qui al
primo eh
alla alla prima, diciamo, la alla prima
cosa qui, no? Eh, questo primo movimento
qui è troppo alto perché siamo già al
top del range, vuol dire che deve fare
uno sforzo che fino adesso non è
avvenuto, quindi è già una una scommessa
troppo grande, no? Pretendere che ehm
tutte le altre volte abbiamo avuto
subito ehm
della responsive action al al top in
questa zona qua e noi cosa andiamo a
fare? andiamo a comprarle proprio qua
sopra, non mi pare proprio il caso, no?
A parte che non
è il caso, semplicemente si fanno in
maniera diversa i i trade momentum.
Si aspetta, ad esempio, che che che il
prezzo abbandoni, che ci sia davvero da
tutta da tutta la curva si monitora, che
ci sia volume sostenuto qua fuori, no?
per dire, ehm, e poi allora si può fare
una specie di retest e vedere magari che
venga costruita l'equilità dietro nel
caso ideale o comunque comprare qua
sopra se ci sono le condizioni adatte
per farlo. In ogni caso uno può mettere
la sua bid qua sotto e attendere.
Qui non lo so se ci sarebbe stato il
fill qua immediatamente, probabilmente
per avere una fill che sia
ideale
e bisognava aspettare a questo punto qui
che era fondamentalmente 5 minuti prima
del della news e quindi è un esempio un
po' del cazzo, però eh l'idea rimane
valida.
Si veniva affillati qua sotto, no? dopo
ben 5 minuti, come ho detto, entrare qua
non è al massimo qua da queste parti.
Magari nel frattempo uno da guidato da
impazienza
provava ad entrarne entrare con uno,
consapevole il fatto che doveva
lasciarne un altro qui dietro, quindi
due lotti su Zen
mettendo uno stop qua sotto. Quindi
questo qui avrebbe dovuto avere 1 2 3
tic di stop.
Sì,
proprio qui, diciamo che proprio qui può
essere rischioso perché a volte, avrete
già notato di sicuro ci sono dei mini
buchini, appena va in bidità
perché si apre, ma durano una quantità
infinitesimale di tempo e vengono
immediatamente riempiti. Ecco, quella è
una situazione in cui con uno stop
volume venete fregati lo stesso. Per
quello, in queste zone qui, ehm,
è abbastanza rischioso mettere uno stop.
è sempre meglio magari metterlo più giù,
ma in ogni caso qua avrebbe comunque poi
questa bid qui avrebbe pagata pagato su
questa idea qui di questo
sbilanciamentino qui, di questo flowing
unidirezionale.
Qui, purtroppo, sempre per le condizioni
che stiamo avendo adesso, il la
distribuzione dei volumi all'interno dei
range è pessima, quindi agli estremi di
questa two way è veramente terribile,
quindi è impossibile venire fillati qui
sul bordo. Bisogna avere più pazienza
con i trade, semplicemente veniamo a
dopo entrambi gli eventi. Abbiamo quello
delle 16:45,
abbiamo quelle delle delle 16, l'ultimo
l'ultimo
movimento a rialzo e poi fine finisce
immediatamente dopo
abbiamo una costruzione di liquidità
bella pesante, bella evidente
dal verso il eh
dalla parte dei dei sellers,
abbiamo anche abbastanza poco interesse
ogni volta che ci andiamo a tradare
dentro. Quindi qua con un pochino più di
volatilità, un po' più di movimento, se
uno gli concede eh un po' di spazio, si
può andare qua, nonostante questa
rimozione qua bella marcata, qua c'è
pochissimo volume e immediatamente si
svende.
la stessa cosa.
E qua
non lo so se poteva sembrare buy,
semplicemente per il fatto che c'era
tanta pressione sell. Probabilmente qua
sotto non si sarebbe comprato,
sinceramente.
Magari sì,
però era parecchio rischioso. Più che
altro si andava a comprare magari solo
sul anche su con l'idea che fosse più o
meno il punto di origine da da di questo
movimento qui, magari pensando ad un
continuo, però anche andando a guardare
i dati non è che ci fosse tutta sta
grande idea
dietro, no? da dire oh i dati sono stati
talmente buoni da dire
ovvio. Adesso i dati sono estremamente
importanti, quelli delle delle
istituzioni private come PMI,
scusate, l'ISM,
l'SNP, perché non abbiamo dati
ufficiali,
però escono e sono mixed, quindi niente
di superlativo, anzi.
Allora, non c'era proprio una un'idea,
un bias da dire super bullish. Infatti
poi ho avuto uno short in questo range,
ma l'ho chiuso, non mi ricordo neanche
bene che prezzo, eh, l'ho chiuso per due
tic. Qui c'è stata
un'idea un po' di rafforzamento. Vedete,
abbiamo un po' lo stesso pattern qua,
no?
Quindi abbiamo poca volume sotto,
eh, immediatamente sopra. Poi qui della
domanda c'è e inoltre si è costruita
dell'aquidità qua sotto. Quindi qui
poteva anche sembrare che se noi
andavamo a mettere una bid qui ci
ritrovavamo nella situazione di dove di
dover eh essendo che ci si si veniva qui
si entrava by probabilmente, no? magari
essendo che magari il il fulcro del
range si sono si è spostato più in
altro, no? Ehm,
questa è una bella two way, è anche
abbastanza voluminosa, più di prima
almeno. Quindi, siccome eh i buyer
saranno qua,
il pulling è stato è successo qui,
magari una bella bid qui uno se la
poteva piazzare, ma cosa succedeva? che
si veniva affillati
da parecchio volume cell immediatamente.
Questa è una situazione in cui se uno si
ritrova con
un
con un ordine cosino che va a swippare
tutta questa liquidità e va a finire al
di sotto, se lo stop non è stato
triggerato
si ritrova a considerare di dover uscire
per uno scratch, anche se poi vedete è
andato oltre, ma non importa, noi siamo
lì Come
>> saresti rientrato lì su questo livello
qua. Non so se mi senti bene perché
credo che
>> Sì, sì. No, ti ho sentito, ma mi ma mi
hai spaventato tantissimo. [risate]
>> No, no, ti sento, ti sento. Sì, è
possibile che sarei entrato qua. Sì, sì,
perché essendo che c'era eh liquidità da
tutti e da entrambi i lati, no? e quindi
che c'era un unaway range di tre tic
abbastanza ben definita, probabilmente
avrei provato a ad entrare qui. Ehm, ma
appunto c'è il c'è il problema di di
invalidazione, nel senso che ehm
sarei stato fillato da t da da
abbastanza volume più anche del pulling
qui, no? Ehm perché eh cioè
il livello è stato completamente
swippato
e io venivo affillato nel peggiore dei
modi, quindi perdendo tutto il vantaggio
possibile, immaginabile che uno si può
immaginare.
Quindi essendo che nella situazione, in
questa specifica situazione eh rimanevo
fillato, sì, ma ehm mi rimanevo
graziato, per così dire, perché a volte
rimaniamo proprio graziati, no? Possiamo
essere tecnici quanto vogliamo. Abbiamo
i nostri punti di ent, abbiamo i punti
di invalidazione e quant'altro. volte la
botta di culo c'è indubbiamente. Quindi
qua era una di quelle volte che qu la
botta di culo c'era perché entri qui due
tic di stop volume, zero volume tradato,
quindi è andato in bid sul eh sullo
stoperato
e quindi qua cominciavo comunque a a
fare working out of the position, a
insomma a tirarmi fuori dalla posizione.
avrei immediatamente messo da quando
succede una cosa del genere che vieni
swippato e entri nel peggiore dei modi,
metti immediatamente lo stop a a break
even e aspetti di di uscire a break
even. qui un'altra volta un'altra grazia
senza che eh venga due tic di stop è
abbastanza stretto da dire non mi metto
a chiuderlo a meno un a meno che uno non
sta magari aumentando la size per la
prima volta allora chiudere a meno un se
proprio non se la sente e lo fa no
perché qua c'è stato un altro swep
quindi se c'era l'occasione magari uno
almeno un tic la chiudeva o magari stai
passando da usare due lotti a quattro
quindi raddoppi la size, c'hai un po'
più di caga, vuoi essere anche un po'
più sicuro, preferisci prenderti una
loss in più e darti l'occasione dopo eh
per un altro trade e allora esci.
Però in ogni caso stop a break even,
quindi un bello scratch
e sarebbe usciti qui, anche se poi
se avevo un take profit di due perché
l'entri era qua, non sarei stato
comunque mai fillato, almeno non in
tempi ragionevoli,
ma a zero riuscivo anche chiuderla,
quindi pagavo soltanto la commissione.
Pagare soltanto la commissione sui
treasury è una cosa molto importante
perché come il buon vecchio Norden anche
insegna è meglio trasformare
una buona porzione di perdite in in
scratch quindi a zero, eh rispetto a eh
lasciarle chiudere, insomma in negativo,
perché poi l'outcome non lo conosciamo,
no? può essere molto vario,
eh, quindi la certezza ce l'abbiamo,
cioè quella di preferire di chiudere a
zero, piuttosto fresh mind. Quello che
dico sempre io, quando una funzione, una
posizione non funziona, è inutile
mediare, sperare,
pregare, bisogna cercare di uscire eh al
meglio favorevole possibile, se è
possibile, quindi a zero, altrimenti,
cioè ehm e e avere la testa eh le idee
chiare, no? Quindi la mente è fresca per
un altro trade, una per avere una
un'idea oggettiva di quello che il
mercato sta dicendo, piuttosto che stare
in una posizione e avere la mente
offuscata, perché poi dopo più tempo si
resta in un trade, eh soprattutto se è
negativo, più la mente diventa offuscata
e pretendiamo dal mercato cose che non
esistono, insomma, no?
Dunque, poi
>> Vabbè, sì, certo. Minimizzare
>> Vai, vai, finisci pure che si sente un
po' male.
>> Eh, non lo so, forse telefono e prego.
>> Continuo a non aver capito, mi dispiace.
Penso che in origine volesse dire che
aveva capito che il punto focale era di
minimizzare il rischio.
>> Ok. Sono prolungato tanto su una cosa,
ma vorrei che fosse abbastanza chiara.
fare lo scratch sui treasur tanta roba
se si riesce e piuttosto che fare loss
proprio perché abbiamo la tick size
molto grande, specialmente su ZB che hai
un $31 al lotto vuol dire che prendere
uno stop in un trade solo sono 62. È
vero che se uno fa tr da un mini das
magari c'ha un due punti di stop
notic sono comunque $100, no?
Però abbiamo l'occasione qua, siccome
sono mercati calmi e pazienti, di avere
l'occasione, appunto, di tagliare corto
e di essere più pazienti anche noi,
insomma.
Andando avanti, poi una mezz'oretta già
dopo la situazione è cominciata a
diventare molto molto più chiara. Quindi
qui abbiamo avuto la prima idea di
aggressività particolarmente
cell'apertura
del floor, quindi l'apertura del
pavimento, poco volume, sempre qua un
esaurimento, quindi classico pattern,
ritorno verso il fulcro, di nuovo un po'
di volume, classico range, no?
all'estremo poco volume, esaurimento,
però a un certo punto abbiamo questa
bella svenditina abbastanza continua che
si è fatta 1 2 3 tic, poi è continuato
fin qua sotto e man mano che faceva gli
scalini a scendere, vedi? Primo cell 513
lotti, poca liquidità qui è facilissimo
per loro riuscire a scendere. Seconda
occasione con solo 196 lotti f swippare
il livello, arrivare fino qui. Qui
comunque abbiamo ehm è aumentata di di
di parecchio la è diventato più marcata
la differenza qui sopra. Qui c'è stata
un po' di di resistenza, ma è stata
completamente surclassata da questo
gigantesco ordine. Qui l'intenzione era
chiara. Si, si noi vogliamo vendere e
hanno venduto
qui. Poi
ehm qui abbiamo di nuovo un'altra volta
l'esaurimento,
un ritorno sopra, ma con pochissimo
volume da qui sotto. C'è proprio qui
sono gli ultimi gli ultimi frangenti in
cui in realtà non c'è poi così tanto
volume in allontanamento dalla zona del
minimo, cioè è proprio andato
mh con poca roba, cioè non non si nota
nemmeno il il volume bias, vedete?
Eh, quasi nulla. Qui hanno avuto
un'ultima occasione, un po' di pulling,
un bel buy.
Qui però zero flow a continuare.
Hanno venduto
immediatamente aggiunta liquidità a
supporto. Quindi abbiamo una specie di
formazione di un primo eh scalino un po'
di sotto. Qui non c'è c'è un rimasta un
una zona un po' più vuota, ma
probabilmente perché questi sono
talmente marcati che adesso questo
risulta
eh meno meno pieno, no? Poi ovviamente
cambiano i colori a a seconda di quello
che è, però in ogni caso si nota la
differenza.
Eh, sellers
passivi a supporto del movimento
che hanno continuato
a tentare di comprare, quindi diverse
volte, però già con una situazione così
chiara non ti deve passare la voglia di
essere un buyer in un range del genere.
Cioè, è vero che noi tradiamo il range e
ci piace quando ci sono questi range,
però se riusciamo a tradarli dalla parte
giusta è meglio, perché se io riesco ad
entrare magari con due lotti e vedo una
situazione del genere in cui c'è eh ho
ho i venditori passivi dalla mia parte
che cercano di supportare, quindi che
c'è tendenzialmente la possibilità di
possibilità, dico sempre di di sviluppo
di di un trend e allora magari c magari
riesco a sfruttarla se sono dal lato
giusto. Se invece sono da quello
sbagliato, ovviamente mi gioco il range,
mi prendo il tic e bassa. Parli entrambi
in una situazione come abbiamo adesso di
volumi e di liquidità è quasi
impossibile perché la distribuzione non
è equa, non è giusta.
Ehm, quindi poi qui hanno fatto un
ultimo continuo, ma niente, hanno
svenduto facilità uscita dal range. Eh,
ultime occasioni per entrare sul treno
prima di entrare, cioè prima di andare.
Qui magari c'era la parvenza ancora un
po', ma qui, ma insomma con tutto ciò
qua sopra,
poi infatti ha guidato tutto quanto
a rimangiarsi tutto quello che aveva
fatto e quindi fare quello che eh
rimangiarsi questa risalita
abbastanza poco sensata sui dati, ma
giusto era abbastanza fisiologica più
che
più che quando si rimangia tutto quanto
così non è perché ci sia
una reale motivazione, ma eh
non importa, no? Il mercato può anche
essere mercato semplicemente perché
mercato. Ci sono dei momenti in cui fa
le cose perché ci sono degli scambi
fine, basta, si va in alto, si fa in
basso, no?
E poi per il resto della sezione, qua
siamo già dove abbiamo fatto la lezione
e non è capitato praticamente nulla.
Allora, abbiamo avuto un termine di
di range abbastanza poco chiaro, una
situazione abbastanza poco chiara, ma è
perché siamo anche verso la fine della
giornata, quindi
qui siamo arrivati al minimo.
Tanto tanto volume buy.
parecchio 7320
aggregato qua ovunque, però
però poi vedo che in ogni caso poi dopo
un po' se l'è mangiata la liquidità qui
sopra, nel senso, quindi alla fine sono
tutti contenti, passivi, aggressivi,
sono rimasti contenti tutti quanti che
hanno avuto quello che volevano.
Diciamo che questo
era abbastanza già un po' tardi,
diciamo, per dire
reversal così.
Ehm, sarebbe stato l'ideale se Vediamo
se magari zoommando da questa parte se
fosse un pochino più
visibile la cosa, ma quando c'è una cosa
del genere ovviamente questo è un
trigger per un entry long, quindi
tranquillamente
non poteva pensare. Però
l'ideale sarebbe stato se fosse stato
più visibile proprio il bid da questa
parte e che dopo questo ci fosse lo
scalino da questa parte, no? Perché poi,
come vi avevo già accennato,
ehm,
questi livelli diventano un po' meno
validi, quindi che ci possa essere
un'inversione del trend oppure uno
sviluppo di range se cominciano a venire
tradati eh mano andando suo
e qua non lo so più cosa.
Tra l'altro dicevi che il minimo era
debole, è stato andato, cioè è stato
proprio ripreso
di un tic e poi è risalito poco a poco.
Quale, scusa? Questo qui.
>> Sì, sì, sì. Era Sì, l'avevi detto su
Discord.
>> Ah, sì, sì.
E vabbè, poi c'è stato l'evento.
>> Eh, vabbè, però poi dopo comunque è
andato, se l'è ripreso
e poi ha fatto il range attuale.
>> Sì.
E poi niente, una giornata in cui,
vabbè, nella giornata Treasury sono
generalmente down, soprattutto per la
Scusa, ma ne user l'hanno già cambiata
loro? Non è non hanno cambiato questo
weekend?
>> No, dovrebbe aver già cambiata. Sì, sì,
l'hanno cambiata, in
>> Ah, ok. Non sono rincoglionito, allora.
Sì, sì, l'hanno cambiato.
>> Ok, ok. No, perché guardavo le ore ero
un po' confuso, dicevo che
eh allora
sto weekend non ho guardato
praticamente niente di preparazione
cose. Guarda che il caso è, cioè
veramente il l'ho messo
il 411 dell'ultima dei Treasury l'ho
messo, ma
e caso vuole che
sia finito proprio qui.
Eh, è salito il BX. Cosa ha fatto l'SPX
oggi?
Non sembra un po' un, se andiamo a
vederlo un po' così
un range di quelli un po' strani in cui
poi magari c'è
c'è un po' di
voi che siete più ferrati di equitist,
qual è la situazione, il pensiero
generale su Spix che
eh
boh,
>> ma io da un po' che lo penso, secondo
me, potrebbe farlo un minimo di presa di
profitto, un minimo di stori.
Non ti dico domani, dopodomani, però
adesso è un po' di sessioni che la
benzina sembra finita.
Eh sì,
>> questa è sarebbe la terza sessione
questa.
Questa cosa qua che ha fatto mi sembra
una cosa che avevo già sembra una cosa
già vista un po'
non so quando, forse 23 anni fa, però
vabbè, sembra sempre, ma tanto vabbè
quando succederà succederà.
loro e loro si è fermato finalmente.
Cioè, finalmente,
però il 4000 vengo,
cioè più o meno
dal TLT,
da il TLT svende parecchio.
TLT è un il più grande ETF
che abbiamo sull'obbligazionario.
Segue
i bond, come dice il nome, 20 anni e
confrontiamo con CB. Vediamo com'è la
situa.
Non lo guardo più di tanto, però
l'analisi delle opzioni su su TLT
potrebbe essere eh
potrebbe essere valida,
ci potrebbe stare perché c'è anche poi
tutti i tool tipo spot gamma
che funzionano in quel caso, no?
Non che segue abbastanza TLT,
Zib, Lubi,
ne segue parecchio.
Su ZN, invece andare a guardare gli open
interest quick strike potrebbe aver
senso.
Sì,
però
poi mi sembra sempre che a guardare
l'openas forse essendo che mi sono
lavato il cervello col fatto che l'open
interest è cacca, non ci ho mai dato più
di tanto peso.
>> Tu cosa ne pensi?
>> Ma eh
oddio, dipende su che mercati.
Comunque sta di fatto che sono posizioni
aperte.
Io più che il puro open interest cerco
di guardare anche i volumi perché i
volumi perché l'open interest essendo
che te lo danno la sera
della sera prima, non sai mai poi se in
open sono aperti o chiusi, mentre i
volumi sono dovrebbero essere
leggermente più attendibili.
Comunque qualcosa dovranno fare sti
cristiani quando ci arriva su su quei
livelli. Certo, ma anche perché andare a
vedere il
le greche
che comunque non è così semplice, ci
sono dei calcoli particolari proprio
apposta per i future, eh per le greche
che sono diversi da dal resto, ma
comunque essendo che gli strike
includono così tanti tic, non lo so se è
così valido, nel senso e siamo in gamma
così o così.
quando in realtà magari tradiamo nello
stesso strike per giorni, no? Quindi
>> No, vabbè, quello
andare a fare un'analisi così avanzata,
no, però vedi c'è solo vedere i due
punti di riferimento, 12 e 25 e 13,
un minimo può aver senso. Infatti
comunque oggi il massimo è stato fatto a
26, se non sbaglio.
>> Sì, sì.
Aspetta, eh,
13. Non non c'è arrivato manco a morire,
però
>> com'era
un modo per
>> Avevo trovato una volta, se non sbaglio,
da qualche parte un modo per
ehm
per per aggregarli
Ah, quello è carino. Potrebbe essere
interessante.
>> Allora, intanto togliamo i eh martedì,
i giovedì, che sono quelli nuovi che
hanno fatto per fare lo zero DTI, che sà
c'hanno 2-3 mesi come prodotti
sono abbastanza
ridere. I più importanti comunque sono
sempre stati venerdì
nei negli infrasettimanali.
aggregato sarebbe già più bello da
vedere. Comunque sì,
vabbè, anche senza aggregarli si vede.
Z5 lo 113,
però oh, cioè ho appena interi tutto
rispetto anche su tutti gli altri.
Non so come
come cazzo avevo fatto a fare quella
roba?
Me lo sto immaginando. O era un'altra
piattaforma?
essere questa, ma il fatto è che è
difficilissima la Quick Strike. Penso
che sia la piattaforma meno intuitiva
che abbiamo mai creato.
>> Oh, sì.
Ovviamente
mi piace guardare la vola, la volatilità
a ridosso di un determinato evento,
giusto per avere un'idea eh
di come potrebbe essere
la reazione,
cazzo
Poi tanto ogni volta che lo guardi poi
sembra di averlo visto per la prima
volta. Pensa che costa se vuoi quella
real time bella completa costa $400 al
mese
>> poi
>> è cosìonna.
>> €400 dollari al mese deve valerne
veramente la pena, eh. $5.000 l'anno.
>> Eh sì,
eccolo. $400 al mese,
però c'era qualcuno che diceva, eh, mi
sembra
forse era proprio Spaghetti Lisbon, eh,
Mountain Trader, e se gli togliessero la
la
Bloomberg, l'unica cosa che vorrebbe per
sostituirla è proprio Quick Strike.
Va bene.
Ah, oddio,
oddio.
>> Forse intende quella,
ovviamente, quella piena, anche perché
gli dà un sacco di roba.
Eh, non non avrei un termine di
paragone, quindi
magari magari è validissima e li vale
tutti e sti $400 al mese. Vai a sapere,
>> magari ti dà anche eh ti dà anche magari
accesso a delle API, a dei download di
dati per farti le tue cose custom, cose
così, no?
che potrebbe essere
>> avrebbe un senso
>> perché poi c'è sia Mi data mine che è
abbastanza costoso sia per i dati
storici che
che per i dati real time è super preciso
ma Madonna se si fanno pagare. Poi c'hai
anche che avevo guardato, c'hai anche
i
hanno un servizio su Google Cloud eh per
far girare dei modelli
eh
ML, quindi algoritmici,
i più famosi, ma che poi puoi anche
modificarti usando i loro stessi dati,
ma c'ha delle cifre veramente
stratosferiche, superine migliaia e
migliaia al mese
Infatti avevamo guardato, ma poi ti
passa la voglia,
eh.
Poi hanno ricominciato ad acquistare.
Ma
>> questa è sempre la Xenit o è o hai fatto
tu la Trading View come la Xenit?
>> Ho fatto la Trading View come Xenit.
Ah, ok, infatti non capivo.
>> Sì, ma Trading View così come come è
integrato Trading View in in Xinit fa un
po' ridere, cioè c'è in Workspace
potevano anche evitare.
È un po' terribile, secondo me. Non puoi
neanche metterti le sessioni divise,
cioè
eh
sì, è abbastanza inutile, però vabbè. Va
bene.
>> Non vuoi uscire dalla piattaforma? Ce
l'hai là.
Tra l'altro ho modificato Workspace, eh,
ve lo ve lo rimando.
Ah,
>> grande. in realtà lo lo me lo rimodifico
ancora in questi giorni, quindi magari
ve lo mando completo perché m
>> Allora,
allora, intanto
i
i monitor sono un po' più organizzati,
meglio. Ce ne sono tre. ha incluso della
roba che si guarda che guarda di meno,
quindi tutti gli swaps
a questo livello. Poi vabbè, qua
c'abbiamo i software. Ehm,
quello che si vede qui è il change in
non in tic, ma in basis points del del
dell'implied, quindi è il contrario.
Ehm,
quindi se se questo è positivo vuol dire
che il prezzo è sceso.
Poi vabbè, questo c'era già,
questo orfano, gli inflation swap, eh
qualche spread in più, tipo lo Z25, Z26
del software
che va a misurare
il numero di tassi attesi tra eh tra
dicembre e dicembre e l'anno prossimo.
Poi ho messo quello tra
dicembre
e marzo,
ma quello che sarebbe interessante
aggiungere è, aspettate che ho filtrato
per open
clear filter.
C'è uno spreadino bellino che è l'F e il
G. Ammazz fa. Ma c'ha il volume non è
c'è non esiste. Cosa devo fare? Che devo
fare
tra
c'è uno di volume. C'è lo spread tra F e
G di software, ma cioè non ha volume.
Cosa devo fare qua? Aspetta,
ho visto che qualcuno lo consigliava
perché quello del meeting di
eh s f-
men- No.
Infatti non c'è neanche i dati. Come ha
fatto a plottare lo spread qua?
Vabboh.
Non mi piace questo spread.
E poi c'è questo lo spread della fine di
di Powell fondamentalmente tra dicembre
e giugno, poi lo salutiamo. È proprio
uno stronzo comunque, eh cioè da da come
da come sta
da come pare la voglia finire, nel senso
di ehm di creare dissenso dissidenti,
no? di di di introdurre le volatilità
tra un meeting e l'altro non era
necessario. Cioè, hai definito un una
strada, la strada da seguire è quella,
lo sa tutto il mercato che quella strada
da definire. Ovviamente c'è sempre il
fatto che tanto l'ultima parola ce
l'hanno loro e non sempre hanno fatto
quello che era, tra virgolette giusto
fare per
in termini di tassi, però
cioè dai, hai detto hai hai detto una
cosa e poi te la rimangi in un meeting
intermedio, quella veramente pesante,
veramente pesante. Sì, sì.
Non c'era alcun bisogno.
>> Vabbè, ma con lo shutdown ci può anche
stare.
Concordo, però posso capire. Via,
mettiamola così.
Comunque aspetto perché
ehm
non riesco a vedermi con un mio amico
che è diventato super esperto di Xenit
già da già da prima, eh che sa bene
utilizzare
le formule nel monitor, che io sono un
po' un culo.
Ehm, volevo farmi
farmi mettere delle formule particolari,
insomma, per che misurano
lo spread, la distanza tra una cosa e
l'altra, il cambiamento nella giornata
di un determinato spread importante,
ehm,
e altre cose.
Ad esempio,
c'abbiamo qua lo swap spread e lo
zpread. Non so se l'ho dato la di
definizione, lo zis spread
è il premio eh di del rendimento che
deve essere eh che deve essere aggiunto.
Vabbè, fondamentalmente lo zpread e lo
spread lo swap spread misurano quello
che è il premio richiesto dai
partecipanti al mercato per detenere una
determinata scadenza più a lungo o meno,
insomma, a seconda della durata, però
avercelo così nel senso che lo spread,
ok, ci sta è a 72, ma il 72 da un mese è
inutile. Quello che voglio io è il
cambiamento nella giornata, no? o del
cambiamento nella settimana che quindi
ti dice vogliono più rischio rispetto a
un momento e altro della della storia
più recente che diventa molto più utile
che cambia ad esempio nelle giornate ad
alto rischio, nelle giornate in cui ci
sono degli assestamenti della curva come
un po' come oggi
in cui abbiamo avuto
un
flattening leggerissimo, non si può
neanche chiamare flatening,
sinceramente.
un restringimento dello spread 210
e un allargamento 530,
uno stipening sul 530, quello vabbè un
po' di più.
Vabbè, in ogni caso, ragazzi, se per voi
va bene io io staccherei, la facciamo
anche un po' più corta.
>> Va bene,
>> va bene, va bene, Devi.
>> Dai, buona cena, buona serata.
>> Ciao ragazzi. Grazie mille.
>> Grazie.